THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET TO ORDER.
JUST GIVE EVERYBODY UPDATE WE
HAVE JUST PASSED ON OUR BUDGET
BILL AB SEVENTY FOUR TO THE
SENATE.
TODAY IN COMMITTEE WILL BE
HEARING.
SEVENTEEN TRAILER BILLS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY IN PRINT.
WE WILL HAVE ANOTHER HEARING ON
ANY ADDITIONAL.
TRAILER BILLS THAT ARE NOT YET
BEFORE US.
WITH ONE TECHNICAL EXCEPTION WE
WILL BE VOTING ON ALL THE
TRAILER BILLS NEXT WEEK.
THE ONE EXCEPTION IS SB NINETY
FOUR WHICH WILL BE AMENDED TODAY.
TO ADDRESS A CHAPTER IN OUT
ISSUE WITH SB THE THREE AGAIN
THE HEARING IS INFORMATIONAL
THERE WILL BE NO ACTIONS TAKEN
TODAY -- IN AGAIN -- APPRECIATE
MY ADVICE JURORS -- COMMENTS ONE
OF THE REASONS WERE HAVING THE
HEARING IS AT HIS SUGGESTION
VERY APPRECIATE THAT TO INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY AND OPENNESS WITH
OUR BUDGET PROCESS -- SO WE
AGAIN -- VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT AND WHAT THAT WILL ASK --
MISTER THIS ONE OFTEN TO PRESENT --
WE WILL START -- I BELIEVE WITH
SB.
SEVENTY SIX MR THAT'S ONE OF THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. SEVENTY SIX
THIS REGARDS K. FOURTEEN
EDUCATION THREE ITEMS OF NOTE
HERE THE FIRST IS PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT SAID A LOT FUNDING
OF SEVERAL HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WILL GO TO K.
FOURTEEN SCHOOLS UNDER THE PROP
NINETY EIGHT GUARANTEE.
A SECOND ARE CHANGES TO THE PROP
NINETY EIGHT CERTIFICATION
PROCESS -- THIS INCLUDES NO
DOWNWARD ADJUSTMENT TO
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT FUNDING --
AFTER FISCAL YEAR HAS BEEN
COMPLETED ALTHOUGH THE JUSTIN
CAN BE UPWARD -- AS WELL AS THE
ELIMINATION OF THE COST
ALLOCATION SCHEDULE AND THE
THIRD IS AN ADJUSTMENT FOR THE
LCF COLA WHICH IS --
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED -- BUT
WHEN THE COLLECTS ITS GROWTH AND
PROP NINETY EIGHT THERE ARE SOME
ADJUSTMENTS UNDER THIS TRAILER
BILL.
THANK YOU COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
THE SERVER NOT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO IF I
UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY WE ARE
FUNDING K. TWELVE EDUCATION
ADJUST THE PROP NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE IS THAT CORRECT. FOR
THIS BUDGET YES THAT'S CORRECT
OKAY WELL I MEAN I YOU KNOW I'VE
HAD THIS DISCUSSION BEFORE BUT I
CONTINUE TO BE OF THE OPINION
THAT PROP.
NINETY EIGHT WAS INTENDED TO BE
A FLOOR NOT A CEILING AND VERY
HOPEFUL THAT IN FUTURE YEARS WE
CAN START.
OF FUNDING OVER THE GUARANTEED
TO TRY AND GET -- OUR FUNDING
REACHES BACK TO WHERE THEY
SHOULD BE.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS.
OKAY -- WITH THAT WE HAVE
[inaudible]
PUBLIC COMMENT.
THE COMMUNIST BE [inaudible]
SEVENTY SIX OKAY SEEING NONE WE
WILL MOVE ON TO SB SEVENTY SEVEN
HIGHER EDUCATION.
SIR SB SEVENTY SEVEN INCLUDES A
NUMBER OF PROVISIONS RELATED TO
HIGHER EDUCATION I WILL JUST
MENTION FOR THAT.
FIRST IS THE INCLUSION OF
CALIBRATED FOR STUDENT PARENTS
OF THESE OUR STUDENTS --
ENROLLED IN OUR OUR COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES WHO ALSO HAVE A
DEPENDENT CHILD OR CHILDREN AND
INCLUDES CAL GRANTS WITH THE
WORD VALUES OF UP TO SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
SECOND I HAVE A NOTE IN THIS
TRAILER BILL IS A DRAMATIC
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANTS OVER 50%.
GOING FROM 250-007-0050 TO ABOUT
FORTY ONE THOUSAND CAL GRANTS --
UNDER THIS AB FIVE FORTY
STUDENTS THAT IS UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS WHO QUALIFY FOR
RESIDENT TUITION WOULD ALSO BE
ABLE TO APPLY FOR THESE CAL
GRANTS THERE'S ALSO FOR THESE AB
FIVE FORTY STUDENTS A CAL GRANT
THE SERVICE CENTER GRANT PROGRAM.
THIRD ITEM OF NOTE IS A SECOND
YEAR OF FREE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TUITION FOR FIRST TIME FULL TIME
STUDENTS.
AND FINALLY -- FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS -- FOR UNDER THE BUDGET
FOR THE CHILD SAVINGS ACCOUNTS --
GRANT PROGRAM IN THIS TRAILER
BILL ESTABLISHES HOW THAT
PROGRAM OF WORK.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEMBERS.
COMMENTS.
MR OBERNOLTE.
SO WE HAD A DISCUSSION ON THE
CALIFORNIA PROMISE MONEY ABOUT.
MAKING SURE THAT ALL COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN CALIFORNIA WERE
ELIGIBLE FOR THAT -- AT THE AYE
ILLUSTRATED WITH THE FACT THAT
NONE OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
IN MY DISTRICT.
CURRENTLY CAN OFFER FREE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO MY
CONSTITUENTS SO WHERE ARE WE
WITH THAT.
YES SO I LOOKED INTO THAT BROUGH
WE LOOKED INTO THAT BRIEFLY AND
I WILL DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUE BUT
THE THE SHORT ANSWER IS THAT --
THE FUNDING FOR FREE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IS CONTINGENT ON THOSE
SCHOOLS ACCEPTING -- FEDERAL
STUDENT AID AND WE KNOW THAT
THEIR NUMBER OF CONSIDERATIONS
THAT GO ALONG WITH THAT BUT I'LL
DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUE CHRIS.
CERTAINLY -- SO ALL THE CULTURES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE CAN
PARTICIPATE -- THERE ARE CERTAIN
REQUIREMENTS THAT THEY NEED TO
MEET SUCH AS THE FEDERAL LOAN
PROGRAMS WE WORK WITH THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WHO IS
ACTUALLY WORKED WITH --
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO HELP
STUDENTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO
ENSURE THAT THEIR COHORT DEFAULT
RATES A STABLE THIS IS GENERALLY
DONE BY.
INSURANCE STUDENTS ARE IN THE
THE PASSED OUT LOAN REPAYMENT
PLANS OFTEN THOSE ARE INCOME
BASED A REPAYMENT PLANS.
SO ARE FURTHER UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT LESS THAN 2% OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS STATEWIDE
HAPPENED ROLE LOANS -- SO WE WE
KNOW THAT THAT THERE IS A
CONCERN IN.
A SMALL NUMBER OF COLLEGES IN
THE STATE HOWEVER WE THINK THAT --
THE EXISTING PROGRAM INSURES
THAT ALL STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO
THE GREATEST FINANCIAL AID
AVAILABLE TO THEM THE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF PROGRAMS -- AND WE KNOW
THAT THE CHANCES OFFICE IS MORE
THAN WILLING TO WORK WITH THOSE
DISTRICTS TO ENSURE THAT THEY
WOULD REMAIN ELIGIBLE FOR ALL
FEDERAL PELL GRANT PROGRAMS.
AND HAVE DEFAULT RATES THAT
WOULD DEFINITELY BE BELOW -- ANY
THAT WOULD TRIGGER SANCTIONS.
WELL I I HAD A DISCUSSION WITH
THE CHANCELLOR OF THE LARGEST
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN MY DISTRICT
AND THE REASON WHY THEY DON'T
PARTICIPATE IS THAT THERE
DEFAULT RATE.
WAS OVER 34% IN THE LAST YEAR
THEY DID PARTICIPATE SO THEY
DON'T FEEL LIKE THEY CAN'T
PARTICIPATE I DON'T THINK IT'S
FAIR TO TIE.
THIS FUNDING THAT'S SUPPOSED TO
BE FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE FOR ALL --
TO CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS
REGARDING THE FEDERAL LOANS
BECAUSE THAT THAT RESULTS IN MY
CONSTITUENTS NOT HAVING ACCESS
TO IT.
THANK YOU MISS.
FOR I JUST TO FOLLOW UP IF YOU
CAN CLARIFY DID YOU SEE THAT
LESSON. 22% OF THE STUDENTS IN
COMMITTEE COLLEGE -- UTILIZE
FEDERAL LOANS.
THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING BASED ON
DATA THAT IS RECEIVED FROM THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
THEN IF THE GOAL OF THE FUNDING
IS TO ENSURE MORE THAT STUDENTS --
PARTICIPATE IN AND ROLLING
COMMITTEE COLLEGE AND I HAVE --
COMMITTEE COLLEGES ALSO OR DON'T
THE FALL INTO THE SAME CATEGORY --
AS WAS OBERNOLTE AND IS THE WHY
WOULD WE HAVE THAT CRITERIA.
I THINK IT GOES TO THAT POINT OF
ENSURING THAT STUDENTS HAVE
ACCESS TO THE GREATEST --
ABILITY -- TO PARTICIPATE IN
FINANCIAL AID OPPORTUNITIES THAT
ARE OUT THERE INCLUDING FEDERAL
LOAN PROGRAMS.
BUT IF IF -- IF FUNDING IS
PROVIDED BY THE STATE TO COVER
THE ENROLLMENT COSTS WOULD AND
THE WIND WE ELIMINATE THE NEED
FOR THEM TO TAKE OUT MORE
STUDENT LOANS.
IT WOULD CERTAINLY REDUCE THEIR
NEED TO TAKE OUT CERTAIN TYPES
OF STUDENT LOANS BUT THAT'S WERE.
WE'VE HAD A CONSISTENT
CONVERSATION -- STUDENT -- COSTS
BY GO BEYOND JUST THOSE SO
TUITION.
OKAY THANK YOU.
IN THIS REGARD THIS MCCARTY YET
THAT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO
ON THIS -- COMMUNICATE AS FREE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ISSUE -- I
CONCUR THAT YOU HAVE RAISE AN
ISSUE -- TO TAKE A STEP BACK
LAST YEAR WHEN WE CREATED THE
BILL SANTIAGO AT YOU MCCARTY
BILL THIS CLAUSE WAS IN THERE
AND IT WAS INSISTED UPON BY THE
CHANCES OPTICS THEY WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT ALL STUDENTS WERE
DRAWING DOWN FINANCIAL AID
THEY'RE ALL APPLYING. FOR THE
FAST SAID IT MAKES THEIR PELL
GRANT ELIGIBLE AND SO FORTH --
THEY MAY NOT BE 100% ONE SIZE
FITS ALL AND I AGREE WITH THAT
THERE THERE'S ANOTHER -- FOR A
PROPOSAL GOING THROUGH THE
PROCESS THIS YEAR AND AS A
FOLLOW UP BILL.
AND SO ON I'M COMMITTED TO KEEP
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE TO TRY TO
SEE WE CAN DO TO MAKE SURE ALL
COLLEGES CAN ACCESS.
THIS -- FREE COMMITTEE CALL
SUCCESS MONEY I APPRECIATE IT
THANK YOU MCCARTY.
THANK YOU COULD BE CORAL.
TING HERE OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
BRO.
CHIU.
COOPER FONG.
FRAZIER [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GARCIA.
JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
LIMóN.
MATHIS.
MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MELENDEZ MULLIN [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
NEWS AREA [inaudible]
O'DONNELL PATTERSON [inaudible]
RAMOS [inaudible]
REYES.
HERE [inaudible]
RIVAS [inaudible]
RUBIO STONE [inaudible]
WEBER.
WHAT WICKS?
WHAT?
COM IS PRESENT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE MEMBERS.
CASING THAT ANY COMMENTS
REPUBLIC.
SINGLE COMES FROM PUBLIC WITH
MOVED TO S. B. SEVENTY NINE
HEALTH.
SO SB SEVENTY NINE REGARDS
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES I'LL
MENTION TWO ITEMS HERE THE FIRST
IS ALLOWING FOR FUNDING FROM THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FUND --
TO FUND THE EARLY PSYCHOSIS
INTERVENTION PLUS PROGRAM WHICH
IS IN THE BUDGET PROPOSAL -- AND
THEN THE SECOND IS EXTENDING THE
DEADLINE FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT INNOVATION FUNDING
FOR COUNTIES RATHER THAN THERE
BEING A SET DEADLINE IT WILL BE
BASED ON A PROJECT PLAN APPROVED
BY THE COMMISSION SO THERE'S A
LITTLE BIT MORE FLEXIBILITY
THERE.
THANK YOU NICK -- QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
SINGLE QUESTIONS ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT.
SINGLE PUBLIC COMMENT WAS MOVED
SB.
EIGHTY TWO SO SB EIGHTY TWO
REGARD TO NUMBER OF ITEMS ON
GENERAL GOVERNMENT ISSUES I WILL
BRIEFLY MENTION FIVE OF THEM.
A FIRST ARE CHANGES TO THE
SAFETY NET RESERVE -- BEFORE WE
HAD FOR THE SAKE YOU NEVER SERVE
SPECIFIC SUB ACCOUNTS FOR MEDI
CAL AND CAL WORKS NOW WE SIMPLY
HAVE A BROADER SAFETY NET
RESERVE AND ARE INCREASING IT
FOR THIS BUDGET PROCESS OF
EVERYTHING IS ENACTED.
FROM TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
AT 201-820-1929 HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS SO IN OVER FOUR FOLD
INCREASE SECOND IN THIS TRAILER
BILL IS THE CREATION OF THE
OFFICE OF DIGITAL INNOVATION AND
I KNOW THAT'S SOMETHING WE'VE
TALKED A LOT ABOUT IN COMMITTEE.
AS WELL AS THE DIGITAL
INNOVATION SERVICES REVOLVING
FUND.
THIRD ITEM IS SUPPORT TO
COUNTIES -- TO UPDATE THEIR
VOTING SYSTEMS IN ADVANCE OF
WHAT WILL BE A PRETTY BIG --
STATE AND FEDERAL ELECTION IN
THE UPCOMING ELECTION CYCLE
FOURTH IS THAT DISPOSITION OF
THE CINEMA DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER
PROPERTY AND THE TRAILER BILL
EXPLAINS HOW THE PROCESS WILL
WORK FOR THAT.
AND FIFTY SOME CHANGES REGARDING --
THE A. B. C. -- COMMISSION FOR
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE IN CONTROL --
SO HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS ON
THAT OR ANY OF THE OTHER ITEMS
IN THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE COMING FRAZIER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF THE
NUMBER THIRTEEN OF THIS ITEM --
PROVIDES THE DEPARTMENT GENERAL
SERVICES THE THIRTY DO INTERNET
GRIMACE OF THE USERS.
OR THE USE ON THE USE OF CINEMA
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER PROPERTY
INCLUDING THE SILL PROPERTY IF.
CERTAIN CONDITIONS CAN BE MET
CAN WE CLARIFY WHAT CERTAIN
CONDITIONS BE MET MEANS.
YES I SHOULD TURN IT OVER TO A
COLLEAGUE WHO'S WE HAVE THAT IN
WRITING IS DELIVERED TO MY
OFFICE WITH THOSE CONDITIONS
WOULD BE PLACE.
SINCE WE'RE HERE WE MIGHT AS
WELL.
SO THE DESCRIPTION OF THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE -- IS A
LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN WHAT -- I
THINK I WOULD HAVE -- WRITTEN.
BUT ESSENTIALLY THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE SETS OUT AN ARRANGEMENT
BETWEEN THE COUNTY OF CINEMA IN
THE STATE REGARDING THE
DISPOSITION OF THE CINEMA
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER WHICH WAS
CLOSED IN DECEMBER.
OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN IT SPECIFIES
THAT THE COUNTY IS GOING BE
RESPONSIBLE.
FOR EXPEDITING IT'S LAND USE
PLANNING PROCESS IN ORDER TO
REZONE THE AREA BECAUSE IT IS A
VERY.
LOCALLY SENSITIVE -- SITE IT
INCLUDES A CEMETERY ON SITE FOR
THE TOWN OF ELDRIDGE PROVIDES
ACCESS TO TWO REGIONAL PARKS --
WEDNESDAY PARKING ONE REGIONAL
PARK AND ALSO AS RIPARIAN WATER
RATES ON SITE.
AND SO IT IT THE RAIN IT
BASICALLY.
STATES THAT THE COUNTY IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR RE PLANNING A AN
EXPEDITED FASHION AND THE STATE
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR MAINTAINING
THE SITE.
UNTIL IT CAN BE DISPOSED OF
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MISTER WILSON.
FOLLOWING UP ON THE ASSEMBLY
PLANTS QUESTION I KNOW THAT THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY HAS OPINED
THAT THE PROCEEDS FROM THE SALE
OF THAT PROPERTY SHOULD BE --
SHOULD BE DEDICATED TOWARDS THAT
COMMUNITY AND I DIDN'T HEAR YOU
TALK ABOUT ANY ANYCOMMITMENT.
TO TO THAT SO FAR WHAT YOUR
THOUGHTS ABOUT.
WHAT THE PROCEEDS WILL BE USED?
FOR MY CURRENT UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT ANY PROCEEDS FROM THE SALE
THE PROPERTY WOULD BE RETURNED
TO THE GENERAL FUND THE GENERAL
FUND CORRECT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE WE WILL GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT ANY MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
WISH TO COMMENT.
OKAY SEE NUMBER GONNA MOVE TO SB
EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU.
SB EIGHTY THREE MAKES A NUMBER
OF CHANGES IN THE TRAILER BILL
OR RELATED TO LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT.
FIRST IS THE EXTENSION OF PAID
FAMILY LEAVE DURATION FROM SIX
WEEKS TO EIGHT WEEKS BEGINNING
JULY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY THIS
IS ACCOMPLISHED IN PART THROUGH
DROPPING THE RESERVE REQUIREMENT
IN THE RELATED FIND.
FROM 45% AT 30% A SECOND MAJOR
CHANGES IN THIS BILL IS THE
PAYROLL DEFERRAL BRINGING IT
BACK THIS OF COURSE AS WE KNOW
WAS DONE DURING A TIME OF FISCAL
STRESS FOR THE STATE.
AND WHEN PAYMENTS AT THAT TIME
WERE TO WAIT IN THE FOURTH
QUARTER FROM JUNE THIRTIETH TO
JULY FIRST -- THIS WILL BRING IT
BACK TO JUNE THIRTIETH SO AS
PART OF PAYING OFF THE WALL JACK
WHICH THE GOVERNOR HAS COMMITTED.
TO A AND THEN THE THIRD ARE SOME
ADMINISTRATIVE CHANGES TO CAL
SAVERS FORMERLY KNOWN AS SECURE
CHOICE.
THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS QUESTIONS
RESTAURANT.
SO WE HAVE A ROBUST DISCUSSION
ON THE PAID FAMILY LEAVE ISSUE
YEAH BUDGET CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
AND I JUST WONDERED IF YOU HAD A
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO DOUBLE
CHECK THE MAP THAT WE'VE GONE
OVER.
ABOUT WHAT THAT'S GOING TO COST
THE AVERAGE CALIFORNIA IN TERMS
OF THEY THE PAYROLL TAX ON THEIR
PAYCHECK.
YES SIR WE DID LOOK INTO IT AND
ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES MAY BE ABLE
TO SPEAK TO THAT AS WELL BUT WE
ARE NOT ANTICIPATING ANY CHANGE
IN THE DEDUCTION IN THE BUDGET
YEAR -- SO IT ALL DEPENDS THESE
ARE ALL ESTIMATES IT DEPENDS ON
HOW MANY PEOPLE TAKE UP TO LEAVE
AND FOR HOW LONG WHETHER THEY
TAKE THE FULL EIGHT WEEKS -- BUT
FOR THE FIRST YEAR OF
IMPLEMENTATION WE'RE NOT
ANTICIPATING A CHANGE.
HI DANIEL BRAND OF A DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE I WOULD ALSO NOTE
THAT WE'RE NOT ANTICIPATINGAN
INCREASE IN THE FOLLOWING A YEAR
AS WELL THE FIRST INCREASE.
WOULD BE AND WE ESTIMATE WOULD
BE AROUND TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND
THAT'S A POINT 1% -- THANK YOU
OKAY SO THE THE AND THAT'S WHAT
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST WAS
SAYING ALSO WAS THAT IN THE LONG
TERM.
THIS HAD THE POTENTIAL TO COST
CALIFORNIANS POINT 1% IN
ADDITIONAL PAYROLL TAX DEDUCTION
WHICH IF THE AVERAGE
CALIFORNIANS WAGES SIXTY TWO
THOUSAND YEAR.
ABOUT SIXTY TWO DOLLARS A YEAR
SO WOULD YOU WOULD YOU AGREE
THAT THAT'S A REASONABLE
ESTIMATE LONG TERM OF WHAT -- OF
WHAT EXTENSION OF THE PAID
FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAM WILL OR
WILL COST.
I GENERALLY I THINK YOU KNOW
THOSE NUMBERS ARE IN LINE WITH
WHAT WE ARE THINKING OF WOULD
MAKE THE POINT THOUGH THAT THAT
MONEY IS NOT BEING USED FOR
OTHER PURPOSES BUT WOULD BE
RETURNED TO PARTICIPANTS WERE.
PAYING THAT IF THEY CHOOSE TO
TAKE PAID FAMILY LEAVE.
I'M SORRY I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU JUST SAID -- SURE SAID
THIS SIDE INCREASE OF POINT 1%
WERE TO HAPPEN IT WOULD BE GOING
INTO THE FUNDS SO IT WOULD NOT
BE USED FOR OTHER.
GENERAL FUND PURPOSES I
UNDERSTAND SO YES. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I OBJECTED TO IS THE
WAY THAT THIS HAS BEEN
CHARACTERIZED AS SOMETHING
THAT'S NOT GOING TO COST
CALIFORNIANS MONEY.
AND THE POINT I'M TRYING TO MAKE
IS THAT YES IT WILL COST EVERY
CALIFORNIAN. SIXTY TWO DOLLARS A
YEAR TO TO AFFECT THIS CHANGE.
SO I THINK ARE ONLY RESPONSES TO
FULL NUMBER ONE YOU KNOW WE
DON'T ANTICIPATE THAT IN THE
NEXT TWO YEARS AND SECOND AND
THIS IS OF COURSE AN ONGOING
PROCESS BUT THIS TASK FORCE IS
STARTING UP AND WE'RE HOPING TO
IDENTIFY THE PATH FORWARD --
THIS IS JUST THE FIRST STEP.
GIVING ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
COMMENTS FROM THE PUBLIC.
SEEING NONE.
LET'S MOVE ON TO SB EIGHTY FOUR
CAL ACCESS REPLACEMENT SYSTEM
PROJECT.
SO ONE MAJOR ITEM IN SB --
EIGHTY FOUR THIS IS -- AN UPDATE
TO CAL ACCESS -- FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NEW ONLINE
FILING DISCLOSURE SYSTEM FOR
CAMPAIGNS IT EXTENDS THE
DEADLINE FOR A FEBRUARY UNTIL
FEBRUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE REASON FOR THIS IS THAT THE
CURRENT DEADLINE WOULD HAVE A
NINETY DAY PERIOD.
RIGHT IN THE MIDST OF THAT STATE --
ELECTION SEASON NEXT YEAR AND
THAT DEADLINE WAS SET BEFORE
CALIFORNIA MOVED UP ITS PRIMARY
NEXT YEAR FROM JUNE TO MARCH
SERVICE PUSHES THAT DEADLINE TO
AFTER THE ELECTION SEASON SO
THAT THERE ARE NO -- THAT THEY
WE HOPE THERE ARE FEWER HICK UPS
AND IT ALSO PROVIDES SIX POINT
NINE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
IMPLEMENTATION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
QUESTION TO THE COMMITTEE.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
OKAY SEE NUMBERS COULD SB EIGHTY
FIVE RESOURCES.
SO THIS RESOURCES AVAIL -- THEIR
NUMBER OF COMPONENTS TO IT ONE
IS SIX AND EXTENSION OF THE
HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND UP
THROUGH JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY
THIRTY SECOND IS THE
ESTABLISHMENT UNDER CAL FIRE OF
AN INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
REVOLVING FUND.
AND THIS BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE
CAL FIRE TO COORDINATE WITH THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE ON FUEL REDUCTION
PROJECTS.
THERE ARE ALSO SOME CHANGES HERE
TO THE OFFICE OF THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL FIRE LIFE SAFETY
CLARIFYING THEIR MISSION
RESPONSIBILITIES -- AS WELL AS
SOME SMALL CHANGES -- REGARDING --
GRF POLLUTION REDUCTION MAKING
SURE THOSE EFFORTS ARE ALIGNED
WITH COMMUNITY EFFORTS.
THANK YOU MISS COOPER.
WE ARE GOING THE GST
IMPLEMENTATION AUDIT PROGRAM WHY
REMOVING THE CAP ON THE TOTAL
AMOUNT OF FUNDS A RB MAY COLLECT.
TO LIVE INSUFFICIENT FUNDS
BASICALLY GIVING THEM A LITTLE
AUTHORITY TO RAISE THE FEES
WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE APPROVAL ONE
OF THIS INCREASE THE CAPS
OFFICIALLY TO COVER THE COST.
OF MOVING THE REQUIRED STATE
PROGRAMS.
SO THE ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES
THAT DATE THROUGH THE
CERTIFICATION PROCESS THE COST
OF PAYING KERR THEY SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO COVER THOSE BUT I
WILL DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUE TO
SPEAK.
BACK TO THE TRAILER BILL DOES
REMOVE THE CAP FOR THE
CERTIFICATION AUDIT AND
COMPLIANCE PROGRAM AS YOU
REFERENCE FOR PHASE TWO OF THE
GREENHOUSE GAS.
REDUCTIONS STANDARDS THIS IS TO
COVER THE REASONABLE COSTS OF
ADMINISTERING THE PROGRAM WE
WOULD NOTE THAT THE REVENUES OF
THE GOING INTO THE CERTIFICATION
AND COMPLIANCE FUND.
AND IT'S GOVERNED BY BUDGET ACT
APPROPRIATIONS SO THERE IS A
MECHANISM BY WHICH THE
LEGISLATURE WE WAYNE IN ANNUALLY
ON THEIR LEVEL OF EXPENDITURES
IN THAT PROGRAM ALSO BY VIRTUE
OF IT BEING IN THE CERTIFICATION
OF COMPLIANCE FIND IN A SEPARATE
FUND IT'LL BE VERY VISIBLE.
AS AN EXPENDITURE REVENUE LEVELS
AS A WAY TO ALSO MONITOR.
THESE ACTIVITIES IN THOSE LEVELS.
OKAY AS MORE QUESTION OR ISN'T
IN THE INDEPENDENT EMISSIONS
MARKET BUYS WE COMMITTEE.
THE PROVISIONAL COMMUNICATIONS
ALSO AUTHORIZED MEETING IN ORDER
TO PROVIDE THEM GREATER
FLEXIBILITY.
WHAT TYPE OF CONVERSATIONS ARE
THERE ARE THESE THE ONLY TO HAVE
THEM IN TOGETHER PRIVATE?
SHE'S CONVERSATIONS GOTTEN OPEN
REALISTIC COLORS CAN PARTICIPATE.
I HAD TO RESET I'M SORRY DINNERS
MYSELF THERESA CALIBER WOULD
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND DEAD
COMMITTEE IS AN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE AND THAT CHANGES BEING
MADE TO FACILITATE.
DISCUSSIONS AMONG THE MEMBERS
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO YOU
KNOW ANALYZING SOME OF THE THE
THE PROGRAMS ARE QUESTIONS
BEFORE THEN WE HAVE TALKED TO
THE AIR RESOURCES.
BOARD ABOUT -- WHAT THAT MEANS
IN PRACTICE THEY DON'T EXPECT IT
TO SUBSTANTIALLY CHANGE HOW THEY
HOLD MEETINGS AND PUBLIC
MEETINGS FOR THIS COMMITTEE --
BUT STILL IT'S STILL IT WOULD BE
JUST PUZZLES ME FOR ANY GROUP
LEGALIZATION WHETHER ADVISED HER
NOT TO MEET IN PRIVATE HEALTH
DISCUSSIONS THAT'S THE COLOR OF
A LOT OF FOLKS WRONG OBVIOUSLY
THE BETTER THE CLEAN AIR ACT.
THE BROWN ACT THINGS LIKE THAT
SO THAT'S THAT'S VERY UNUSUAL
FOR ANY TYPE OF BODY SO CAN YOU
DOUBLE THAT FURTHER.
NO I'M I HAVE I DON'T KNOW THEY
HAVE TOO MUCH MORE DETAIL OTHER
THAN I KNOW IT WAS DONE TO THE I
CAN FACILITATE THOSE DISCUSSIONS
BUT THERE IS NO -- INTENTION BY
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD TO KIND
OF CHANGE THE NATURE OF THE
MEETINGS THEY HAVE NOW WHICH ARE
HI MY UNDERSTAND IS PUBLIC AND
SO.
THAT'S KIND OF THE EXTENT OF THE
INFORMATION I HAVE THAT WE CAN
KEEP LOOKING INTO IT AND TRY TO
GET BACK TO YOU WITH MORE THAT
THE GREAT THANK YOU OKAY
[inaudible]
MISTER FOE.
I JUST TO FOLLOW UP ON A MISTER
COOPER'S QUESTION ARE THEREANY
OTHER COMMITTEES OR AGENCIES
THAT ARE EXEMPTED FROM THE BIG
THE KLEENEX.
THE VAGUELY KEEN OPEN MEETINGS
ACT.
I DON'T HAVE THAT INFORMATION ON
HAND SO THAT WOULD BE ANOTHER
THING WE HAVE TO FOLLOW UP WITH
ON THE BUDGET COMMITTEE SOUTH
WANTING TO GET OF A BIGGER
PICTURE BUT I DON'T I DON'T KNOW
HOW OFTEN AND HOW THAT
INFORMATION.
OKAY I MEAN I I SURE MISTER
COOPER'S CONCERNING IT JUST
SEEMS THAT.
WE SHOULD HAVE MORE TRANSPARENCY
NO LESS [inaudible]
THIS FRAZIER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF MOVING
BACK TO NUMBER ONE ON THIS WITH
THE MISTER COOPER TO DRESSED.
THIS ORDINARILY WOULD HAVE GONE
THROUGH MY COMMITTEE IS THE
CHAIR TRANSPORTATION AND
REMOVING THE CAP CONCERNS ME.
GENERALLY BECAUSE IT'S ON ON AND
WE'RE NOT REPORTED TO ON A
REGULAR BASIS SO IF THESE THINGS
HAPPEN -- ONE WAY WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR ABOUT IT IS IT'S THE PUBLIC.
LETS US KNOW -- SO I DO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT GIVING ANYBODY
UNBRIDLED AUTHORITY TO RAISE THE
RAISE THE CAP ARRAYS.
OF FEES WITHOUT SOME KIND OF
CHECK BOUNCING CHECK IN PLACE.
GOING FOR SO THIS THIS -- ONE I
REALLY NEED TO HAVE IT OR
DRESSED IN A I THINK A MORE
TRANSPARENT AND ALSO -- SECURE
MANNER FOR FOR THE THE MORE
REPUBLIC.
IN ADDITION TO THE BUDGETARY
PROCESS MENTIONED EARLIER THE
FEES REQUIRE REGULATIONS IN
THOSE WILL GO THROUGH THE NORMAL
PUBLIC -- REGULATIONS PROCESS BY
THEIR RESOURCES FOR SO THAT'S
ANOTHER -- FACET OF THIS YEAH I
THINK I WOULD PREFER THIS GOES
THROUGH THE POLICY COMMITTEE
ALSO ON ON THAT.
ON THAT FASTENED BUT WHAT I'M
SAYING IS.
THAT -- ANY AGENCY THAT HAS
UNBRIDLED AUTHORITY TO RAISE
FEES WITHOUT -- SOME KIND OF
BOUNCING CHECKS BUDGET COULD
JUSTIFICATION -- CONCERNS ME.
THANK YOU -- MISTER YOUNGER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN -- I
WANT TO FOCUS IN ON THE WILD
FIRE FUEL REDUCTION PROJECTS AND
YOU KNOW FIRST OF ALL -- COMMEND
THE ADMINISTRATION ON ITS WORK
TO DO THE THIRTY FIVE PROJECTS
STATE WIDE -- STREAMLINED
PROJECTS TO REALLY GET OUT THE
FUELS REDUCTION MY CONCERN IS
THAT IN THIS TRAILER BILL THERE
WERE REQUIRING.
CONSULTATION WITH WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
AND DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE -- IN MY CONSUMER DOES
IT THIS WOULD SLOW DOWN I MEAN
THE IDEA IS A STREAMLINED WE
NEED TO GET TO THESE PROJECTS
QUICKLY.
WE NEED TO REDUCE THE FUEL LOADS
AND ARE AND ARE FORCED IT AREAS
IN OUR WILDLAND INTERFACES --
TOO YOU KNOW BECAUSE TO ME
THAT'S ONE OF THE GREATEST
FACTORS INVOLVED IN THESE --
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES -- SO.
YOU CAN YOU SPEAK TO THIS OF ME
HAVING THIS CONSULTATION
REQUIREMENT TO ME SEEMS LIKE
IT'S GOING.
TO POTENTIALLY SLOW DOWN -- THE
STREAMLINED PROJECTS.
STEPHEN BENSON DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO WE WERE VERY CAREFUL
IN THE CRAFTING OF THE LANGUAGE --
TO INSURE THAT CALIFORNIA HAS TO
COLLABORATE WITH THE OTHER
AGENCIES -- MEADORS KINDA SEEK
THE ADVICE OF BUT THE OTHER
AGENCIES DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY
TO DELAY THE PROJECTS JUST CAL
FIRE IS GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY GO AND GATHER INFORMATION
EXPERTISE FROM THOSE OTHER
AGENCIES.
IN HOW THEY MAKE DETERMINATIONS
ON THE PROJECTS.
SO DOES THAT MEAN IS WILL BE A
FORMAL CONSULATE IS THAT RIGHT.
THE VERY I GUESS BECAUSE I USE
THE TERMINOLOGY MISS LIKE A
CONSUL IN TERMS OF LIKE THEY
DON'T MEAN THERE'S NOT LIKE SOME
SORT OF APPROVAL PROCESS RELATED
TO IT IT'S THEIR THEIR REQUIRED
TO GO OUT AND HAVE CONVERSATIONS
AND GET.
GET ADVICE -- LIKE I THINK
THEY'RE NOT LIKE SUBMITTING SOME
SORT OF FORM WAITING FOR TO GET
APPROVED AND STAMPED AND SIGNED
OFFER PERMIT OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT IT'S JUST IT'S IN DOWN AND
TALKING WITH BOAT WITH FOLKS IN
AND GETTING INPUT.ON THE DECISIONS.
AND THAT WON'T RESULT IN SLOWING
DOWN THOSE PROJECTS.
THAT IS WHAT WE'RE COMMITTED TO
IS NOT SLOWING DOWN THE PROJECTS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WHAT.
IT'S JUST A QUESTION ABOUT THE
IMPROVED INFRASTRUCTURE
MANAGEMENT REVOLVING FUND FOR
CALIFORNIE ME DESCRIPTION WHAT'S
THE SIZE THE FUN WORK WHAT KIND
OF IT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT LIKE.
INFRASTRUCTURE RELATED TO CAL
FIRE STATIONS OR WATER WE
TALKING ABOUT HERE.
SO THIS FUND IS VERY SIMILAR TO
WHAT -- PARKS HAS FOR ITS
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROGRAM.
IF THERE'S NO ACTUAL FUND
BALANCE THAT JUST SITS IN THERE
DOESN'T HAVE A REVENUE SOURCE
WHAT HAPPENS IS WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE APPROPRIATES FUNDING
FOR A PROJECT.
THAT FUNDING CAN BE TRANSFERRED
INTO THIS REVOLVING FUND AND THE
BENEFIT F IT IS THAT IT HELPS
TO ENCUMBER FUNDS THAT.
SO NORMALLY IN A CAPITAL PROJECT
YOU WOULD INCOME FOR MOST OF THE
FUNDS WITH CONTRACTS -- THERE'S
THIS PORTION OF THOSE PROJECTS
FUNDS THAT ARE RELATED TO LIKE
PAYROLL FIRST STATE PEOPLE THAT
WORK ON IT.
THE WAY THE PAYROLL SYSTEM WORKS
IN ACCOUNTING YOU CAN ENCUMBER
THOSE AND SO IT ALLOWS YOU PLACE
TO ENCUMBER THE FUNDS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE OVERSIGHT OF THE
PROJECTS AND THE CONTRACTORS --
CAN REMAIN THROUGH THE TERM OF
THE CONTRACT TO RE CREATING A
FUND BUT WE'RE NOT PUTTING ANY
MONEY IN IT UNTIL THE
LEGISLATURE APPROPRIATES --
CORRECT.
I THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THIS REST [inaudible]
NUMBER.
SEVEN IS THIS RELATED TO EIGHT
AB [inaudible]
SIX SEVENTEEN NUMBER.
SEVEN BUT THIS IS ON THE
COMMUNITY EIGHT EMISSION
REDUCTION PROGRAM.
AND COULD YOU PLEASE EXPLAIN
WHAT THIS WHAT WHAT.
SEVEN WHAT WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
YES THIS IS AN RELATED AB -- SIX
SEVENTEEN TRADITIONALLY WE'VE
HAD THESE PROVISIONS IN OUR
BUDGET BILL OR PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE THE ACTION AND AND AND
CONFERENCE WAS TO MOVE THOSE
INTO STATUTES OF THIS IS NOT
REFLECTED IN TRAILER BILL BUT IT
NEARS.
THAT PROVISIONS THAT HAVE
TYPICALLY BEEN CARRIED IN THE
BUDGET BILLING PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE FOR THE PROGRAM.
GOOD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
PUBLIC COMMENT.
YES MISTER CHAIR JENNIFER
FEARING ON BEHALF OF DEFENDERS
OF WILDLIFE IN THE MOUNT LINE
FOUNDATION WE DON'T OFFER
SUPPORT -- FOR THIS TRAILER BILL
IN PARTICULAR THE EXTENSION OF
THE HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND
AND WANT TO EXPLICITLY SINGLE
OUT THE LEADERSHIP OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM IN YOU TERM AND
TING FOR MAKING THIS -- HAPPEN.
THANK YOU.
THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
OKAY SIGNALS COULD SB EIGHTY
SEVEN TRANSPORTATION. THREE
ITEMS TO HIGHLIGHT ON SB EIGHTY
SEVEN THE FIRST IS THE REPAYMENT
OF ALL OUTSTANDING
TRANSPORTATION LOANS THIS
AMOUNTS TO OVER BILLION DOLLARS
AND THIS ALSO IS PART OF PAYING
OFF THE WALL JACK FROM THE LAST
RECESSION.
SECOND SB ONE HAD ESTABLISHED --
INSPECTOR GENERAL AT CALTRANS
AND THIS TRAILER BILL WOULD
STRENGTHEN THE OFFICE OF AUDITS
AND INVESTIGATIONS AT CALTRANS
MAKING SURE THAT.
COMMUNICATIONS WITH THEM CAN BE
KEPT CONFIDENTIAL AND THEN THIRD
THIS TRAILER BILL ESTABLISHES
THAT THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION
STATEWIDE COMPETITIVE GRANT
PROGRAM FOR SHORT LINES RAIL
[inaudible]
MR FUNG.
IN TERMS OF THE THE
TRANSPORTATION.
DEBT SERVICE.
AFTER IT'S PAID -- FOR MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE THIS
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE LA OR THIS
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ALLOWS THE
CONVERSION OF THE ONE POINT TWO
BILLION.
INTRO QUITE FEES AND JUST WHICH
OF TRANSPORTATION FUNDS TO NOW
BE A PERMANENT GENERAL FUND
TRANSFER IS THAT CORRECT.
NO THE END IN TERMS OF THE USE
OF WEIGHT FEE OF MARKET REFORM
TO FINANCE ARE -- THE AND IN
TERMS OF THE USE OF WEIGHT FEES
FOR DEBT SERVICE THAT'S IT IN
CURRENT LAW.
HUESO THEN ONCE SO IF THERE'S NO
DEBT SERVICE WHAT WHERE DOES THE
TRUCK WAY FEES GO.
I HAVE TO GET BACK JOHN THAT.
I ADMIT I THINK WE'VE GOT.
ENOUGH DEBT SERVICE FROM PROP
WOULD BE FOR TO GO FOR A NUMBER
OF YEARS RIGHT BUT THEN BUT THEN
IT AFTER THAT.
RIGHT WHAT HAPPENS TO DROP
WEIGHT FEES MAY ONCE YOU ONCE
ONCE THE DEBT SERVICE IS
COMPLETED MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT IT EVENTUALLY BECAUSE THE
GENERAL FUND SO.
THEY ARE YOU CONCERNED OR IS
THERE ANY CONCERN FOR THE
MINISTRATION THAT THIS PROPOSAL
FOR NON TRANSMISSION PURPOSES
ONCE IT GOES INTO THE GENERAL
FUND.
NO NO -- NO AND AND SAID IT
CLEAR FINDER CURRENT LAW -- THE
WE HAVE -- DANIEL WAIT FEES GO
TO PAY THE ANNUAL DEBT SERVICE
AND UP TO A CERTAIN POINT IN A
FEW YEARS AGO WE HAD -- ENOUGH
WEEK FEES TO KIND OF BANK SOME
OF IT AND THEN -- WE'VE BEEN
PAYING THAT DOWN I THINK THROUGH
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO IS THE
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY ONE WILL
BE THE LAST YEAR THAT WE HAVE.
YOU KNOW KIND OF BANK TO WAIT
FEES THAT WE WOULD USE TO PAY
DOWN DEBT SERVICE SO -- ALL THIS
BILL DOES IS IT TAKES THE IT
FUNDS THE AMOUNT THAT WE WOULD
REPAY IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE FOR
THE SERVICE AND JUST REPEAT.
REPLACE A YEAR EARLY TWO SO POST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IT DOESN'T IT
DOESN'T APPLY THAT'S CORRECT.
SO.
EIGHT SO IT WOULD STILL BE%
POSSIBLE TO BE USED FOR
TRANSPORTATION PURPOSES.
POST -- TWENTY TWENTY ONE THERE
WILL.
THERE WE NO MORE PAINT TO BE
USED.
RIGHT SO THERE SO THEN THEY'LL
BE AT ONE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS OF TRUCK WAY FEES THAT'S
BEEN COLLECTED.
THAT MONEY WOULD STAY CAN BE
USED FOR TRANSPORTATION PURPOSES.
ABSURD THAT WILL CONTINUE TO BE
USED SO.
OVER THE LONG TERM FROM.
I CAN'T A FIVE TEN FIFTEEN YEARS
PROBABLY -- THAT AMOUNT WILL
CONTINUE TO BE USED ANNUALLY
DANIEL THAT ONE POINT TWO
BILLION WILL BE USED FOR ANNUAL
DEBT SERVICE COSTS.
AND SO THE AMOUNT THAT SAID HERE
IS REALLY RELATIVE -- TO TO I
GUESS RECALL OF BORROWING THAT
WE HAD DONE I'M RESEARCH -- IN
RICHMOND PAST YEARS WE HAD MORE
WEIGHT FEES AND WE NEEDED FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUAL YEARS DEBT
SERVICE.
THIS THIS BILL ONCE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IS DONE WOULD MAKE
THAT LAST PAYMENT.
THAT'LL BE DONE AND AFTER THAT --
WILL BE IS ALL WAIT FEES FOR
DEBT SERVICE ANY AND WITH THE
AND I GUESS THAT THE I GUESS AS
TO CONFUSE OR MAYBE THAT'S WERE
TALKING TO EACH OTHER BUT OPPOSE
WHEN TWENTY ONE THERE IS A
SERVICE.
ORDER THERE THERE'S ONE PLENTY
OF THAT SERVICE YES BUT BUT ON
TRANSPORTATION ON TRANSPORTATION
IS OBVIOUSLY THAT PROP ONE B.
YES OKAY.
AND THEN HOW HOW MUCH THAT
SERVICE WOULD BE HOW MANY HOW
MANY YEARS OF DEBT SERVICE WOULD
BE PROPERTY.
I HAVE TO GET BACK JAY WOULD SAY
AT LEAST TEN YEARS OKAY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
CAN THE PUBLIC ON OKAY SAYING
NONE DISCARDED AS BEING.
NINETY TWO SO SB NINETY TWO
DEALS WITH TAXATION AND REVENUE
A COUPLE OF ITEMS OF NOTE HERE
FIRST -- IN THE BUDGET AGREEMENT --
THE DIAPER AND FEMININE HYGIENE
SALES TAX EXEMPTION THIS WILL BE
FOR TWO YEARS COMPLETE EXEMPTION
FROM JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY
THROUGH DECEMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WITH THE BACK FILL
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THROUGH
TWENTY ELEVEN REALIGNMENT OF
LOCAL REVENUE FIND.
A SECOND THIS BILL -- THE
ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE -- HAD
BOTH PASSED THE AB ONE FORTY
SEVEN BILL EARLIER THIS SPRING --
COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS WAY FAIR
THIS CLARIFIES THE RULES RELATED
TO THAT DEAL SPECIFICALLY -- THE
DEFINITION OF MARKETPLACE
FACILITATORS THIRD -- FOR SALES
TAX AT BACK TAXES COLLECTION FOR
CD TFA THIS BILL LIMITS TO LOOK
BACK PERIOD -- IN RELATION TO
THOSE TAXES WE WERE DISCUSSING
TO THREE YEARS AND FINALLY A
STREAMLINING RELATED TO THE TA
THIS IS THE OFFICE OF TAX
APPEALS.
IF AN INDIVIDUAL OR A BUSINESS
HAS A CLAIM THAT IS UNDER A
CERTAIN AMOUNT -- THIS TRAILER
BILL WOULD ALLOW THAT CLAIM TO
BE HEARD BY ONE ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW JUDGE RATHER THAN A PANEL OF
JUDGES.
THANK YOU MISTER.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO
REGARDING THE A DIAPER AND
FEMININE HYGIENE SALES TAX
EXEMPTION WHEREABOUTS DISCUSSION
ABOUT THIS AND A CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE.
THE LEGISLATURE DID NOT WANT A
SUNSET ON THAT THAT EXEMPTION
AND THE ADMINISTRATION WANTED TO
YOUR SUNSET AND ADMINISTRATION
GOT ITS WAY SO THE QUESTION IS.
DO YOU INTEND TO REPEAL THAT TAX
IN TWO YEARS.
SO THAT TAX SUNSET ON ITS OWN --
I THINK THAT IS A QUESTION FOR
FUTURE WHY JUST WAGER AND
ADMINISTRATION AND IT'LL BE
BASED ON PRIMARILY THE PHYSICAL
CONDITION OF THE STATE AT THAT
TIME WHICH YOU KNOW WE HAVE A
PROJECTION BUT IT'S REALLY
ANYBODY'S.
GUESS AS WELL AS ANY ASSESSMENT
OF THE IMPACT OF THESE -- TAX
EXEMPTION.
OKAY WELL I CONTINUE TO BELIEVE
THAT -- THE POLITICAL
FEASIBILITY FOR PEELING ATTACKS
LIKE THAT IS VERY LOW SO.
I THOUGHT I THINK WE SHOULD JUST
BE HONEST ABOUT IT AND SAY THIS
THIS IS A PERMANENT EXEMPTION
INSTEAD OF A SUNSETEXEMPTION --
IT AND DEAL WITH THE FINANCIAL
CONSEQUENCES OF THAT NOW RATHER
THAN KICKING THE CAN DOWN THE
ROAD TO FUTURE LEGISLATURE'S BUT
UNDERSTAND OUR POINT OF VIEW
[inaudible]
THIS.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE ENGAGE IN ON ON THE ISSUE
OF MINSTREL EQUITY.
HI NOTICES THAT FAR FROM WHERE
WE HAVE BEEN FOR THE LAST FOUR
YEARS -- I I DO WANT TO MAKE THE
POINT OF THAT SEPARATE FROM
BEING HONEST OR NOT THAT WE
THINK ABOUT THE MESSAGE WE'RE
SENDING ABOUT.
A WOMAN'S BODY OUR BIOLOGY.
BEING REMOVED FROM THE LIST OF
LUXURIES BUT ONLY FOR TWO YEARS --
AND THE MESSAGE THAT WE SHOULD
BE SEVEN ABOUT THIS BEING
PERMANENTLY -- HOW WE?
TELL YOU SEE ON THIS BODY CENTER
BIOLOGY AND IT'S IT'S NOT A
LUXURY.
AND IT SHOULDN'T BE USED THEIR
UTERUS SHOULDN'T BE USED TO
BALANCE OUR BUDGET DOWN THE ROAD
RESPECTABLE WHAT OUR FINANCIAL
STABILITY LOOKS LIKE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SONORA COME IT'S GOING TO PUBLIC
COMMENT IN THE PUBLIC ON SEEING
NINETY THREE SB NINETY THREE
DEALS WITH CORRECTIONS -- WITH
TWO ITEMS -- THE FIRST ONE IS A
AN AUGMENTATION FOR CDC ARE FOR
A HUNDRED TWELVE POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS THIS IS FOR
CONTRACT MEDICAL SERVICES
PHARMACEUTICAL AND SOME OUT OF
STATE COSTS.
I WANT TO MAKE TWO POINTS IN
RELATION TO THIS FIRST IS THAT
THESE ARE COSTS FOR THE CURRENT
YEARS -- TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN
TWENTY NINETEEN THEY'RE NOT
COSTS INCURRED IN THE BUDGET
YEAR SECOND I WANT TO CLARIFY
THAT THE STATE IS STILL ON TRACK
TO REMOVE ALL INMATES FROM THE
ARIZONA FACILITY.
BY THE END OF THIS FISCAL YEAR
IN A COUPLE WEEKS BY JUNE
THIRTIETH.
TWENTY NINETEEN SECOND ITEM IN
THIS TRAILER BILL IS A SMALL
AMOUNT OF REIMBURSEMENT -- FOR
MARIPOSA COUNTY FOR A HOMICIDE
CASE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THE COM FOR THE COMMITTEE CA
NINETY COME FROM THE PUBLIC.
NOW LET'S GO TO SB.
NINETY FOUR SB NINETY FOUR DEALS
WITH PUBLIC SAFETY AND I WANT TO
MENTION FOR ITEMS IN THIS BILL.
FIRST IS THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE BEING
TRANSFERRED FROM CDC ARE -- TO
HHS AND THIS TO BE RE CHRISTENED
AS THE DEPARTMENT OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION.
SECONDS ARE A NUMBER F ITEMS
RELATED TO THE APPS THIS IS THE
ARMED AND PROHIBITED PERSON
SYSTEM -- THERE'S A BACKLOG AS
WE'VE DISCUSSED IN COMMITTEE AND
SO THIS BILL WOULD CLARIFY
REPORTING LANGUAGE AND METRICS
OF THAT A LEGISLATORS IN THE
ADMINISTRATION ARE INFORMED
ABOUT THE EXTENT OF THE BACKLOG
AND THE HOW WELL THE STATE IS
DOING IN REMEDYING THAT BACKLOG.
FIRST I'M SORRY THIRD A ARE SOME
REPORTING METRICS AROUND POST
THIS IS THAT COMMISSION PEACE
OFFICER STANDARDS AND TRAINING.
REGARDING THAT EXTRA TRAINING
FUNDING AND HOW THEY'RE USING IT
AND SOME METRICS ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT.
AND FINALLY ETS -- FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE CARE THIS IS
CALIFORNIA REENTRY INTO IN
RICHMOND GRANT PROGRAMS TO HELP.
FACILITATE RE ENTRY SERVICES.
THANK YOU.
MR SORE YES AND I I WANTED.
KOMMENDE AT THE GOVERNOR ON ON
ON JUST TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND JUST BRING IN A
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
LOOKING AT IT IN A NEW LIGHT --
THE DEPARTMENT OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION I GUESS IS.
WHAT YOU YOUR PLAN TO CALL IT
YEAH -- I PROBABLY WOULD HAVE
CALLED IT PROMPT DEPARTMENT OF
AT PROMISED TO DOUBT.
BARTON BUT IN THAT.
YOU GET TO CHOOSE WHAT NAME YOU
WANT TO CALL IT -- BUT THE THING
I I REALLY AM ENCOURAGED ABOUT
IS THAT YOU WILL HAVE SOME KIND
OF HE TO LOOK AT HOW THIS IS
CREATED I THINK THAT'S GOING TO
BE REALLY IMPORTANT.
THE FACT IT WILL KEEP COMING
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE ALL THE
WAY TO TWENTY TWENTY FIVE IS
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT.
AND SO -- WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
WHO'S GOING TO MAKE UP TO CHILD
WELFARE COUNCIL THAT WILL
ULTIMATELY DECIDE THIS SO WE CAN
GET A HANDLE ON THAT -- TOO I
THINK IS REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT
ON THE ARM PROHIBITED PERSON
SYSTEM.
THAT -- WE HAVE OVERSIGHT AND
NOT ONLY HAD ANNUAL REPORTS BUT
WE HAVE NO MORE EXCUSES ABOUT
NOT CLEANING UP.
THE APP SYSTEM AND THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE WORKING WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN IT AND THE
SENATE.
THAT WE GET THIS DONE FINALLY
I'VE BEEN HERE.
A SEVEN YEARS AND EVERY YEAR I
GET ANOTHER OR EVERY TWO YEARS
AGO ANOTHER EXCUSE WE SHOULD NOT.
TOLERATE ANY MORE EXCUSES TO GET
THIS DONE AND SO I I APPLAUD.
THAT CHEERED THAT WE'RE MOVING
IN THAT DIRECTION AND THEN ON
THE THE GRANTS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA RE ENTRY AND RICHMOND
GRANTS I KIND OF WANT TO GET
WHAT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS YEAR KIND OF THE
FEEL WOULD FALL INTO THAT
CATEGORY.
I'VE HAD MANY THAT ARE WORKING
REAL BILL TATIAN WITHIN THE
SYSTEM THE COMMUNITY BASED
COMING IN.
THAT ARE LOOKING FOR GRANTS AND
SO I WOULD WANT TO GET AN IDEA
TO SEE IF THEY CAN APPLY -- I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT --
DID YOU NEED GROUPS THAT HAVE OF
DOG TRAINING AND THE ACTORS
GUILD AND OTHERS THAT -- WE WE
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE INCLUDED.
AND THEN -- THE THE FINALLY
THERE'S A THERE'S SOMETHING I'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT FOR QUITE
SOME TIME IT WAS CDC ARE WHEN I
TALK ABOUT.
RETURN ON INVESTMENT IN MAKING
SURE THAT WE WE SHOW HOW THESE
PROGRAMS HAVE.
GIVE YOU SYNDICATE RETURN ON
INVESTMENT WANTED THINGS THE
LAST CD C. R. WHICH I SEE IS IN
HERE WHICH I AM EXTREMELY HAPPY
ABOUT.
IS I BASS WHEN SOMEONE IS
RELEASED AFTER GOING TO A
PROGRAM LEARNING A TRADE OR
WHATEVER.
HOW DO YOU KNOW WHERE THE NOT
THE RECIPIENT THEY ALWAYS TELL
ME THEY DON'T KNOW?
AND I SAID SOMETIMES VERY EASY
BY.
GETTING A SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER
CHECKING WITH WHETHER NOT THEY
PAID THEIR STATE TAXES COULD
TAKE PAY THEIR STATE TAXES
UNLESS THEY'RE VERY GOOD
CRIMINALS.
GOING NINE TO FIVE WORK EVERY
DAY AND THEN THEY'RE BEING
CRIMINALS AFTER AFTER WORK LET'S
DO A VERY GOOD AND CAN STAY UP
ALL NIGHT THEY'RE NOT DOING THAT.
AND WHEN I ASKED WHY DON'T YOU
CHECK WITH THE STATE FRANCHISE
BOARD THEY SAID WOULD THEY CAN'T
THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO DO THAT.
AND THEY THEY PROBABLY NEED
LEGISLATION AND A SIT IN FRONT
OF ME I GOT YOU KNOW I'M ONE OF
A HUNDRED TWENTY PEOPLE CAN
ACTUALLY MAKE THAT LEGISLATION
HAPPEN.
WHY HAVEN'T YOU EVER COME TO US --
SO A LOT OF A LOT OF WHAT WE CAN
DO TO PROVE THAT IS REAL BILL
TATIAN PROGRAMS WORK AS RIGHT IN
FRONT OF US AND WE DON'T AND CDC
ARE WE DON'T MAKE THIS SPECIAL
EFFORT. TO TRY TO ACTUALLY GET
THAT DONE I THINK THAT WILL HELP
THEM IN THE LONG RUN IN THIS
PART ABOUT WORKING WITH -- CDC
ARE TO PROVIDE A SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS RELEASED INDIVIDUALS TO
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT AND THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD TO
TRACK LABOR MARKET ANOTHER
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT OUTCOMES.
WILL HAVE.
A DRAMATIC IMPACT ON HOW MUCH
MORE MONEY WE NEED TO PUT INTO
REHABILITATION SO I COMMEND YOU
ON THAT.
THIS RESIDENTS QUESTION.
MISS COOPER THE FOLLOWING UP ON
MISTER JONES LAWYERS QUESTIONS
ABOUT RECIDIVISM AND SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS WE KNOW MOST
FOLKS DON'T GO BACK TO A PRISON.
MAJORITY YOU'RE BEING SENT TO
COUNTY JAIL SO WHAT I DO FOR THE
COUNTY JAILS ALSO BECAUSE THEY
HAVE SOME WE HAVE PROGRAMS THAT.
ARE DIPPING A WHO YOU ARE
EFFECTIVELY INEFFECTIVE SO.
WE KNOW IS HALF OVER THERE SO
WHY NOT DO IT WITH THE OTHERWISE
YOU LOOK AT THE TOTAL PICTURE
VERGE RECIDIVISM RATE IS.
SO FOR SOME REASON WERE ALWAYS
EXCLUDING THE SHERIFF'S SO THE
B. B. TO INCLUDE HIM TO GET A
BETTER PICTURE.
WE SPELL OUT OF MONEY THERE THIS
FAR AS THE ABORTION THAT PIECE
OF TRAINING FUND WAS A FOR MONEY.
FOR MONEY BEING USED FOR AGAIN.
SORRY WE WERE GOING -- TO IN THE
BUDGET AGREEMENT INCREASES
FUNDING FOR THE PEACE OFFICER
STAY OFF YOUR CHECK A PEACE
OFFICER TRAINING FUND THAT YEAH
LOS MENSAJES.
WHAT IS THAT EXACTLY?
COME DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE EIGHT
IT GOES TO THE SAME PURPOSES IT
JUST USED TO BE A SUBSIDIARY
FIND AT THE STATE PENALTY FINES
SO AS REVENUES DECREASED TO THE
STATE PENALTY FINE.
WE WENT AWAY FROM HAVING
SUBSIDIARY FUNDS AND WE JUST
HAVE WE'RE FINDING EVERYONE
DIRECTLY FROM THE STATE POLICE
FIND SO IT'S REALLY TECHNICAL IN
NATURE.
TO SORT OF CAUGHT UP BY OUR
EXISTING BUDGET PRACTICES FOR
STE THANK YOU.
THE THE QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
GOING TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
YOU HAVE NO GOING BACK IF THE
ELEVATOR CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
IN SUPPORT OF THE BALLOT OR THE
BUDGET MEASURE -- PARTICULARLY
AS INTEREST IN.
TRANSITION TO PROGRAMS THAT ARE
REHABILITATED SINCE IN NATURE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEE NO ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC COMMENT.
LET'S MOVE ON TO SB. NINETY FIVE
TWO MAJOR CHANGES IN SB NINETY
FIVE BOTH OF THEM RELATED TO THE
COURTS THE FIRST -- AS PART OF
THE BUDGET AGREEMENT IS THE
INCLUSION OF TWENTY FIVE
ADDITIONAL JUDGESHIPS AND THESE
WOULD BE ALLOCATED BY THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL.
AND THIS COMES AT A COST OF
THIRTY POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND THE SECOND
IS AN INCREASE IN THAT TRIAL
CORPORATE SERVE CAP FROM 1% 23%
EFFECTIVE JUNE OF NEXT YEAR
WHICH WILL GIVE OUR TRIAL COURTS
A LITTLE BIT MORE FLEXIBILITY IN
THEIR BUDGETING.
THANK YOU MISTER BROWN.
TO JUST LIKE TO THANK YOU THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE TWENTY
FIVE JUDGESHIPS IT'S GONNA GO A
LONG WAYS TOWARDS RESTORING
ACCESS TO JUSTICE FOR THE PEOPLE
THAT WE REPRESENT.
HAD A QUESTION ABOUT RAISING THE
TRIAL COURT RESERVE CAP -- IS
YOU KNOW THAT CAP WAS IMPOSED
AND DURING THE GREAT RECESSION.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE COURTS
SPENT THROUGH THEIR RESERVES
BEFORE THEY NEEDED STATE
ASSISTANCE.
THE QUESTION IS WHY DOES THERE
NEED TO BE A CAP ANYMORE BECAUSE
THERE WASN'T ONE BEFORE WHY IS
3% THE RIGHT NUMBER OF 1% NOT.
SO THE ADMINISTRATION DEFINITELY
WANTED TO INCREASE THE CAP YOU
KNOW NOW THAT WE ARE OUT OF THE
RECESSION I THINK YOU'LL FIND
WITH A NUMBER OF THESE PROGRAMS.
THERE ARE GENERALLY CAPS IN
PLACE AND I THINK THE REASON IS
ONE IT MAKES AFFECTED BUDGETING
PRACTICE WHERE YOU WANT --
INSTEAD CITIES TO HAVE RESERVES
BY IF THEY HAVE SUCH LARGE
RESERVES WELL BEYOND WHAT THEY
NEED THEN I THINK IT FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR LEGISLATORS
FOR TAXPAYERS YOU WONDER WHY ARE
WE APPROPRIATING MORE MONEY TO
THEM WHEN THEY HAVE SUCH A BIG
QUESTION.
WHEN THAT MONEY COULD BE USED
FOR OTHER PURPOSES BUT SO IT'S A
BALANCE BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT RESERVE IS NOT TOO
SMALL BECAUSE IT CAN MAKE
PLANNING VERY UNPREDICTABLE?
BUT WE ALSO BELIEVE ESCORTS OR
OTHER ENTITIES TO HAVE A HEALTHY
RESERVE THEN THAT MONEY CAN BE
USED FOR OTHER PURPOSES.
OKAY WELL I MEAN I THINK THAT
THERE WERE SOME BAD ACTORS WHEN
THE RESERVE WAS IMPOSED THE CAP
WAS IMPOSED.
BUT MOST OF OUR TRIAL COURTS ARE
NOT BAD ACTORS AND THEY REALLY
STRUGGLE WITH THAT RESERVE CAP
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT EVEN 3% IS
JUST.
A COUPLE WEEKS.
OF RESERVE WHICH IS NOT VERY
MUCH MONEY IS VERY DIFFICULT FOR
TRIAL COURTS TO BUDGET FOR
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS FOR
EXAMPLE THAT ARE THAT ARE
OUTSIDE THE NORMAL COURSE OF
BUSINESS FOR THEM SO.
I CONTINUE TO BELIEVE THE REALLY
WE DON'T NEED A RESERVE CAP
ANYMORE BUT % BETTER THAN 1%.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER.
COMMENTS THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY SEE NO MORE BECAUSE THE
CLEANING THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEE NUMBERS MOVE ON THE SB.
NINETY SIX SIR SB NINETY SIX
REFERS TO THE STATE EMERGENCY
TELEPHONE NUMBER ACCOUNT THIS IS
THE SPECIAL FINDS THAT FUNDS
IMPROVEMENT TO THE NINE ONE ONE
SYSTEM THAT WAS ON THE VERGE OF
INSOLVENCY.
AND SO WHAT THIS TRAILER BILL
DOES IS IT CHANGES THE CURRENT
SYSTEM WHICH CHARGED A FEE ON
INTERSTATE VOICE CALLS ON AS
MANY OF YOU KNOW AS MORE PEOPLE
SHIFT FROM VOICE CALLS TO
TEXTING AND OTHER FORMS OF
COMMUNICATION.
THE FEE REVENUE WAS DECLINING
THREATENING OUR ABILITY TO FUND
FURTHER IMPROVEMENTS FOR NINE
ONE ONE SYSTEMS AT EXACTLY THE
TIME WHEN WERE INCREDIBLE
EXPERIENCING INCREASING
WILDFIRES AND OTHER EMERGENCIES.
AND PEOPLE ARE REALLY RELYING ON
UPGRADES TO THAT SYSTEM BUILDING
REDUNDANCIES INTO IT SO THAT
WHEN PEOPLE CALL 911- EMERGENCY
THAT CALL WILL BE RELIABLE AND
IT WILL REACH DISPATCH QUICKLY.
SO WHAT THIS TRAILER BILL DIES
IT'S WHICH IS FROM AN
INTERESTING VOICE COFFEE TO A
FLAT FEE ON ACCESS LINES -- IT
WOULD BE UNDER THIS TRAILER BILL
BETWEEN ZERO AND EIGHTY CENTS WE
ARE ESTIMATING FOR THE FIRST
YEAR THAT THE FEE WOULD CON MAN
AT THIRTY FOUR CENTS SO THAT
SUBJECT TO A NUMBER OF VARIABLES --
I'D BUT WE BELIEVE THAT THIS FEE
WILL ENABLE -- THE
ADMINISTRATION THE STATE TO
REPLENISH THAT ACCOUNT AND FUND
THE IMPROVEMENTS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S ARE COUNTING ON
THANK YOU.
MISTER RELATED.
IF WE ESTIMATE THAT -- YES NEEDS
34% SPUR LINE TO FUND NEXT GEN
NINE ONE ONE WHERE WE
AUTHORIZING THEM -- TO FOR A
SURCHARGE OF UP TO EIGHTY CENTS.
SO I THINK THE MAIN REASON IS
BECAUSE THIS IS -- TRAILER BILL
AND GOES IN THE STATUTE WE DO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS
FLEXIBILITY BUILT AND NOT JUST
FOR THIS YEAR FOR NEXT YEAR BUT
FOR MANY YEARS IN THE FUTURE
BECAUSE UPGRADING OUR NINE ONE
ONE SYSTEM IS NOT A ONE YEAR OR
TWO YEAR.
I'VE AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE CONTINUALLY I
WILL POINT OUT THAT AT THROUGH
THE ANNUAL BUDGET ACT -- SO THIS
FEE WILL RAISE MONEY FOR THAT
SPECIAL FUNDS BUT HOW THAT MONEY
IS SPENT IN OVERSIGHT IS A LOT
UP TO THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION.
SO THE BALANCE OF THAT FIND AND
THE NEED TO INCREASE THE FEE --
WILL ULTIMATELY DEPEND IN MANY
WAYS ON HOW MUCH THE LEGISLATURE
WANTS TO APPROPRIATE OUT OF THAT
ACCOUNT FOR UPGRADES TO THE NINE
ONE ONE SYSTEM WELL I THINK
WE'RE ALL.
FANS OF UPGRADING TO NEXT GEN
NINE ONE ONE BUT I'M SURE I'M
NOT ALONE IN OPINING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
AN ACTIVE ROLE.
IN OVERSIGHT OF THAT PROJECT AND
TO AUTHORIZE A MAXIMUM CAP OF
OVER TWICE WHAT'S REQUIRED SEEMS
A LITTLE FOOLHARDY.
LIKE TO ASK YOU SOMETHING ELSE
ABOUT THAT THE WHICH IS.
REALLY MY BIGGEST PROBLEM WITH
THIS PARTICULAR TRAILER BILL WE
HAVE A TWENTY ONE BILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET SURPLUS THIS YEAR.
WHY IS IT NECESSARY TO INCREASE
TAXES?
ON OUR CONSTITUENTS IN HERE ONE
OF BUDGET SURPLUSES THAT LARGE
RICHEST THE OPTICS OF IT ARE
TERRIBLE.
SO OUR VIEW OF THIS IS THAT WE
ARE SWITCHING TO A SYSTEM THAT'S
FOLLOWED BY YEAH I THINK FORTY
SEVEN OTHER STATES YOU KNOW --
SO WHERE WELL BEHIND THE CURVE
CALIFORNIA COMPARED TO HOW WE
STRUCTURE OUR NINE ONE ONE FEES
SO THERE IS A NINE ONE ONE FEE
IN PLACE IT'S JUST NOT
ACCOMPLISHING THE PURPOSES. FOR
WHICH WAS INTENDED BACK IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE OR WHEN
WE FIRST REALLY STARTED STANDING
UP THE NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM.
AND WHEN IT COMES MORE BROADLY
TO THE SURPLUS THAT YOU
MENTIONED -- WE OF COURSE
BELIEVE THAT MOST OF THAT
SURPLUS AS MUCH AS ALMOST 90% IS
BASED ON ONE TIME FUNDING AND
BECAUSE WE'VE YOU UPGRADING THE
NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM AS AN ON
GOING PROJECT.
WE DO BELIEVE IT NEEDS TO BE
MATCHED WITH AN ONGOING SOURCE
OF FUNDING WELL THEN I WOULD BE
IN FAVOR OF FUNDING IT.
THIS YEAR OUT OF OUR RESERVE OUT
OF OUR A SURPLUS IN IN FUTURE
YEARS IF WE DIDN'T HAVE THE
MONEY TO FUND IT THEN GOING TO
CALIFORNIANS.
AND ASKING THEM TO FUNDED
BECAUSE ASKING THEM TO FUNDED
NOW.
IN A YEAR WHEN WE HAVE SUCH A
LARGE SURPLUS I THINK IS
UNCONSCIONABLE.
I WILL MAKE ONE FINAL POINT
WHICH IS THAT THIS FEE I BELIEVE
GOES INTO EFFECT ON JANUARY --
TWENTY TWENTY OF TWENTY TWENTY
SO FOR THESE LAST SIX MONTHS --
IT DOES NCLUDE A GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION AS THE NEW FEE
STRUCTURE IS BEING SETTING UP
MOBILE WE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY WE
COULD EASILY FUNDED IT NEXT YEAR.
AND COME BACK THE YEAR AFTER
THAT IF WE DIDN'T HAVE A SURPLUS
ANYMORE [inaudible]
THIS REVIEW.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- WITH A
FOLLOW UP QUESTION ON THAT HOW
MUCH DO WE EXPECT TO RAISE WITH
THE THIRTY FIVE CENTS -- THE
FIRST FIVE YEARS.
AND SO IT THIRTY FOUR CENTS --
WE AND ON A FULL YEAR IS IT
MISTER MISS MISS ONE OFTEN YEAH
I JUST POINTED OUT THAT -- IT
GOES INTO EFFECT JAN FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY SO THE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET
IS ONLY ASSUMING SIX MONTHS AT
THAT RATE BUT A FULL YEAR AT
THAT RATE WOULD RAISE ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS.
OKAY SO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION SO -- THE ADDITIONAL
FIVE CENTS WOULD NOT BE A BEGIN
IF WE DID ONLY FORTY CENTS
INSTEAD OF EIGHTY CENTS TO FIVE
CENTS WOULD NOT BE A BIG ENOUGH
CUSHION.
IS WHAT YOU'RE SAYING THAT'S
WHAT WE NEED THE EIGHTY CENTS.
SO THE WAY THAT THE THE TRAILER
BILL IS SET UP IS THERE'S A VERY --
TYPE PARAMETER CALCULATION ON
HOW THE FEE IS SET. TO THE CAP
UP TO EIGHTY CENTS BUT YES HAS.
VERY MINIMAL -- CONTROL OVER HOW
THAT ACTUALLY IS CALCULATED SO
THE WAY THAT IT WORKS IS.
THE FUND BALANCE IN SET NOW IS
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT.
AND THEN THE LEGISLATURE'S
ANNUAL AMOUNT OF PREPARATION
FROM SET NOW.
AND THEN THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
ACCESS LINES THAT ARE REPORTED
BY SERVICE PROVIDERS -- TO YES.
SO THERE'S NOT REALLY A
DISCRETIONARY PIECE ON YES IS
PART IN HOW THAT FEE IS
CALCULATED.
ONCE THE LEGISLATURE MAKES A
DETERMINATION ON HOW MUCH THE
PERFORATED FROM SET NOW.
THEY WILL ESSENTIALLY DIVIDE
THAT AMOUNT BY THE NUMBER OF
ACCESS LINES AND THAT'S WHAT
DETERMINES WHAT THE FEE WILL BE
FOR THAT FOR THE UPCOMING FISH
CARRIER RIGHT THANK YOU -- BUT
YOU KNOW EARLIER IN THE A
PREVIOUS TRAILER BILLS WE TALKED
ABOUT THE THE RESERVES THAT 3%
RESERVES VERSUS THE 1% AND AND
THE STATEMENT WAS YOU KNOW WE
WANT TO CAPITA WE DON'T WANT TO
HAVE TOO MUCH OR NOT ENOUGH.
AND SO IN MY OPINION THE YOU
KNOW HAVING THEIR A FEET UP TO
EIGHTY CENTS -- SEEMS LIKE OVER
50% OF WHAT WE ACTUALLY NEED AND
SO -- I'M JUST CONCERNED THAT
WE'RE LEAVING IT THAT BIG OF A
CUSHION OPEN AND I WOULD FEEL
COMFORTABLE WITH THE FORTY CENTS.
GIVING US THE FIVE CENT QUESTION
AS OPPOSED TO FIFTY FIVE CENT
CUSHION AND THAT'S BASICALLY
JUST.
MY OPINION -- BUT OBVIOUSLY YOU
KNOW WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO
UPGRADE THE SYSTEM AND I THINK
WE'RE ALL IN FAVOR OF THAT IT'S
JUST.
YOU KNOW HAVING THE QUOTE ON
QUOTE FLEXIBILITY UP TO EIGHTY
CENTS IS KIND OF AS A CONSUMER
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT TO EXPECT I
KNOW IT'S ONLY EIGHTY CENTS WE
OXY IT WOULD ONLY EIGHTY CENTS
BUT A LOT OF OUR POPULATION AND
EIGHTY CENTS COULD.
YOU KNOW.
IF YOU HAVE THREE OR FOUR LINES --
KANNADA UP.
QUICKLY AND I THINK THAT'S WHY
MOST THE DISCRETION IN HOW THEY
GET SAID IS ACTUALLY LEFT TO THE
LEGISLATURE WHEN IT DETERMINES
HOW MUCH APPROPRIATE FROM THE
FUND.
SO IT IS GOING TO BE AN
OVERSIGHT BY THE LEGISLATURE
EXACTLY LEGISLATURE IN THE
BUDGET EVERY YEAR WILL DETERMINE
THE AMOUNT OF CORPORATE FROM
THAT FUND AND THAT IS THE
LARGEST DETERMINANT IN WITH A
FEW GET SET AT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WHAT.
YES THANK YOU SO SO IS THERE AN
ANNUAL REPORT ON THIS OR IS THIS
JUST WE ASK FOR THE INFORMATION
AND THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS.
HAS TO THE FUN CONDITION
STATEMENT THAT'S PUBLISHED IN
THE BUDGET EVERY YEAR WOULD
INDICATE WHAT THE EXPENDITURE
AND REVENUE ASSUMPTIONS ARE AND
AND THAT WOULD YEAH WE OKAY
STATEMENT DOESN'T A SELFLESS THE
FEVER IT LISTS ALL THE
INFORMATION THAT USED TO
CATHOLIC THE FEES WE CAN VERY
EASILY GIVE.
YOU THAT.
NOTE THE FOLLOW UP QUESTION --
SO I REPRESENT A LARGELY RURAL
AREA AND WITH INCREASED RELIANCE
ON SO TECHNOLOGY -- THAT BECOMES
PROBLEMATIC FOR A LOT OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS IN THE FIRES IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN WE
ACTUALLY HAD AN ENTIRE.
AREA I WOULD GO OUT BECAUSE OF
THE INABILITY TO COMMUNICATE SO
WITH SOME OF THIS MONEY THEN.
GOING FOR ADDITIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WILL HELP.
IN THESE HARD TO REACH CELLULAR
AREAS WHEN PEOPLE NEED TO REACH
NINE ONE ONE DURING EMERGENCIES
AND IS THAT IS THAT PART OF THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BECAUSE I WILL
TAKE IN IN ABOUT 4250% OF MY
DISTRICT SOMETIMES THERE'S
THERE'S NO CELL COVERAGE AT ALL.
SO -- DURING AN EMERGENCY IN
YOUR TRYING TO TRACK PEOPLE DOWN
FOR THEY ARE TRYING TO TRACK
PEOPLE DOWN IT'S REALLY
DIFFICULT -- AUTOMOBILE
ACCIDENTS -- CUT OFF BECAUSE OF
LANDSLIDES THESE ARE THINGS THAT
HAPPEN EVERY YEAR IN MY
DISTRICTS SO.
SO ARE WE ARE WE WORKING ON THE
INFRASTRUCTURE -- AS WELL OR IS
THIS JUST TO MAINTAIN THE
CURRENT.
HELLO STATUS QUO SO THE FUNDING
THAT WILL BE.
AND THEN THE NEXT GENERALIZED.
PROGRAM DOES BUILDING NEW
TECHNOLOGY FOR HOW THE NINE ONE
SYSTEM WORKS IT DOESN'T INCLUDE
ME UP WHEN I CAN BE FUNDING LIKE
NEW CELL TOWERS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT SO IN TERMS OF LIKE.
CELL COVERAGE.
THIS DOESN'T IT YOU KNOW
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS THAT BUT IT
IS HELPING TO ADDRESS.
THE RELIABILITY OF THE NINE ONE
ONE SYSTEM ITSELF SO THAT LIKE
FOR EXAMPLE RIGHT NOW IN A MAJOR
INCIDENT THERE ARE TIMES WHEN
DISPATCH CENTERS GET OVERWHELMED
CALLS GO UNANSWERED -- OR THEY
GET ANSWERED YOU KNOW IN WELL
OVER THREE SECONDS WHICH IS THE
THE KIND OF THE TARGET.
THE BIG FOCUS OF THIS IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DON'T HAVE NINE ONE
ONE CALLS GOING ON ANSWERED THAT
ALL NINE ONE CALLS GET ANSWERED
QUICKLY.
IF A DISPATCH CENTER HAS TO BE
EVACUATED BECAUSE OF AN INCIDENT
THOSE CALLS CAN BE READ
REDIRECTED TO A NEIGHBORING
CLOSE DISPATCH CENTER SO THAT
THE CALL STILL GET ANSWERED
PEOPLE STILL GET -- DIRECTION IT
ALSO.
PROVIDE SOME -- OVERTON WARNING
COMPONENTS SO THAT YOU CAN HAVE
WHICH IS KIND OF REVERSED NINE
ONE IF YOU WILL WHERE THEY'LL
HAVE THE ABILITY TO KIND OF PUSH
INFORMATION OUT TO NINE ONE ONE
FOLKS SO I RATHER THAN THIRTY
PEOPLE CALL IN -- TO REPORT THE
SAME INCIDENT YOU KNOW SOME
POINT I BELIEVE THE HAVE THE
CAPABILITY.
TO RECEIVE REPORTS NAME PUSH OUT
INFORMATION TO THE FOLKS IN THE
AFFECTED AREA.
BASED ON CELL COVERAGE THINGS
LIKE THAT SO THAT'S REALLY THE
KIND OF THE FOCUS INCIDENTS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS ROBERTS.
THANK YOU IT AND FOLLOWING UP ON
THE ON THAT DISCUSSION -- AND
SOMEBODY OF COUNTY WE DO HAVE A
LOT OF REMOTE AREAS THAT ARE
THERE.
AND HOPEFULLY -- LOOKING AT THIS
IN HERE IN THE DISCUSSION --
PREVIOUSLY FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WHAT'S QUESTION.
THE NEXT THE RECEPTION BETTER IN
THE REMOTE AREAS THAT ARE THERE
THAT WE CAN SAY THAT WE'RE
EXPANDING.
THAT AREA AND WITH THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE SCENE THE
THINGS THAT ARE GOING ON IN THE
REMOTE AREAS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND TAKING TO IT.
IN ACCOUNT THIS WHOLE STATE IN
THE GEOGRAPHICAL LOCATIONS IT
WILL MOVE FOR WITH THE NINE ONE
SYSTEM.
AND THE CAP OF EIGHTY CENTS.
SO TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
COVERAGE ISSUES ARE BECAUSE OF A
CELL TOWER COVERAGE THIS ISN'T
GOING TO ADDRESS THAT SO FOR
EXAMPLE YOU KNOW IF VERIZON OR
EIGHTEEN TO YOU WHOEVER YOU KNOW
THAT SERVICE PROVIDER IS.
DOESN'T HAVE COVERAGE IN A
PARTICULAR AREA.
THIS ISN'T GOING TO BUILD CELL
TOWERS PROVIDE THAT KIND OF
COVERAGE THIS IS GOING -- TO
ENHANCE AND IMPROVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THE STATE FIRST
RESPONDERS USE -- ON THE NINE
ONE ONE AND AND THEIR ABILITY TO
RECEIVE CALLS BUT I WILL MAKE
THE ADDITIONAL POINTS SO -- MY
COLLEAGUES RIGHT IT'S NOT A WE
CAN'T EXPAND CULTURALLY NOT
CENTER THE PURVIEW OF THAT CELL
PHONE PROVIDER COMPANIES
THEMSELVES -- BUT FOR PEOPLE IN
RURAL AREAS WERE ESPECIALLY
DEPENDENT BECAUSE THEY MIGHT NOT
BE NEAR A MEDICAL FACILITY OR
NEAR AN EVACUATION CENTER.
THEY ARE IN SOME WAYS RELYING ON
NINE ONE ONE BEING ABLE TO GET
THROUGH IF THEY DO HAVE COVERAGE
IN THIS COULD BE FROM A LAND
LINE ALSO NOT NECESSARILY.
A CELL PHONE MORE THAN ANYONE
ELSE SO THIS REALLY MOVES TOWARD
THAT TARGET OF HAVING THAT CALL
BE ANSWERED IN THREE SECONDS OR
LESS.
IT IS A GREAT -- DIALOGUE AND IN
A IN A TOPIC RIGHT FOR FOR
PUBLIC SAFETY BUT I WOULD HOPE
THAT THE DISCUSSION OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURAL ASPECT OF THE
REMOTE AREAS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
DOESN'T STOP THE DISCUSSION HERE --
PROVIDED THIS DOES BEFORE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
MAYBE IF I CAN JUST HAVE YOU
START BY EXPLAINING THE NEED FOR
THIS TRANSITION AND THIS FEE.
IT SEEMS AS IF AS WE AS
CONSUMERS OF ALL FROM LAND LINES
INTO CELLULAR LEAVE USE THAT
THERE WAS A NEED FOR THIS P. AND
WAS HOPING THAT YOU COULD SPEAK
TO THAT A LITTLE BIT.
SURE YEAH THE EXISTING FEE
STRUCTURE IS BASED ON A
PERCENTAGE OF NOT LESS THAN A
HALF A PERCENT NOT MORE THAN
THREE QUARTER PERCENT.
IS ASSESSED ONLY ON INTEREST
STATE VOICE COMMUNICATION SO.
WHAT'S HAPPENED OVER TIME AS
PEOPLE OF TRANSITION AWAY FROM
THOSE KIND OF VOICE
COMMUNICATION ACCESS LINES IS
THE AMOUNT OF REVENUE THAT'S
BEING COLLECTED HAS DECLINED
STEADILY -- THE LAST ACTUAL SO
FROM TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN AND THAT FEE OLLECTED
ABOUT SIXTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
IN REVENUE WHERE IS THE KIND OF
BASS LINE ON GOING --
EXPENDITURES FOR THE NINE ONE
PROGRAM ARE RIGHT AROUND A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS SO.
WE'VE BEEN HAVING TO DO OTHER
THINGS OR DEFER COSTS LIKE FOR
EXAMPLE CAPS NET IS A A PROGRAM
ARE PROP PROJECT THAT IS
CONVERTING OR DIGITAL.
MICROWAVE SYSTEM ARE SORRY FOR
ANALOG MICROSYSTEMS TO DIGITAL --
WE HAD TO DELAY THAT PROJECT
BECAUSE THERE'S NOT SUFFICIENT
FUNDING IN SET NOW TO PAY FOR IT --
AND SO THIS WILL HELP SUPPORT
THAT TRANSITION -- WILL ALSO
PROVIDE A LONG TERM STABLE FUN
SOURCE TO MAKE SURE THAT -- WE
DON'T CONTINUE TO HAVE FUNDING
SHORTFALLS FROM SENATE -- TO
SUPPORT THAT ONE PROGRAM --
HAVING WORKED IN A NINE ONE ONE
SYSTEM I'M SUPPORTIVE OF THE
EVOLUTION OF TECHNOLOGIES AND
HOW ADDING TEXT MESSAGES OR FACE
TâM FACE TIME MAY.
ALLOW ENABLE SOME OF OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS AND INCREASE OUR
ABILITY TO DEAL WITH EMERGENCIES.
I THINK WHAT I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT IS.
PROBABLY A MORE SIMPLE QUESTION
WHICH SUBCOMMITTEE TO THESE
FUNDS GO THROUGH.
AND WHO DO I WORK WITH HERE TO
MAKE SURE IT'S WORKING FOR
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE.
IT IS BECAUSE YOUR SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER -- FIVE SO IS THE NUMBER
WEBER.
THANK YOU SIR.
OKAY SIGNAL THE COMMENTS.
THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
RESOLUTION MUCH LOWER ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF SB --
NINETY SIX WHICH WOULD PROVIDE
FAIR US A STABLE FUNDING FOR
DEBT CURRENT AYE ONE SYSTEM SO
WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT AT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COULD HAVE INTENSELY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATIONOF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT OF THE STRIP ABOUT.
THANK YOU SEE NO ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC COMMENT LET'S GO DO SB.
NINETY SEVEN SO SB NINETY SEVEN
MAKES A NUMBER OF CHANGES IN THE
TRAILER BILL RELATED TECH
CANNABIS AND CANNABIS REGULATION.
THE FIRST IS THAT IT AUTHORIZES
LICENSING AUTHORITIES TO ISSUE
CITATIONS AS WELL AS
ADMINISTRATIVE FINES FOR ANY
VIOLATIONS.
A SECOND EIGHT EXTENDS THE
REPEAL DATE FOR PROVISIONAL
LICENSE PROVISIONS TO JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FIVE IT ALSO
EXTENDS THE SEQUEL EXEMPTION --
AND THIRD IT ENHANCES THE
CANNABIS LOCAL EQUITY GRANT
PROGRAM -- THROUGH A NUMBER OF
PROVISIONS AND I'LL JUST MENTION
ONE IT AUTHORIZES THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT.
ON BEHALF OF THE BUREAU OF
CANNABIS CONTROL -- TO AND
MISTER PROVISIONS FOR THE REVIEW
IN GRANTING A FUNDING FOR THESE
CANNABIS EQUITY PROGRAMS BUT
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF ITEMS IN
THIS BILL AND HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS.
MISS LEAVE OUT.
THANK YOU CHAIR I WANT TO START
OFF BY AT ACTUALLY THINKING OR
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE FOR
BEING SO THOUGHTFUL AND ENGAGING
SEVERAL MEMBERS -- SEVERAL WHO
ARE NOT ACTUALLY HERE -- ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE.
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR US TO CONSIDER AT HOW WE AS
A STATE CAN BE SUPPORTIVE OF
WHAT THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA --
VOTED FOR A AND MOVING THIS
FORWARD BUT CERTAINLY AS A LOOK
AT WHAT SOME OF THE TRADE OFFS
ARE -- IN THIS BUDGET TRAILER
BILL THERE ARE A FEW ITEMS
SPECIFIC SPECIFICALLY ITEM SIX
AND TEN THAT THAT I I I WANT TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND -- IT'S IT'S
CLEAR THAT THERE ARE DISTRICTS
ARE IN VERY DIFFERENT PLACES
WHEN IT COMES -- TO CULTIVATION
LIGHT MANUFACTURING AND SALE --
OF CANNABIS -- ALTOGETHER AND AS
A DISTRICT AND THAT REPRESENTS
35% OF THE ENTIRE STATES
CULTIVATION AND WE HAVE LEARNED
A LOT ABOUT WHAT SOME OF THESE
TRADE OFFS ARE.
AND ONE OF THE CONCERNS I HAVE
IS SPECIFICALLY RELATED -- TO
THE SEQUEL EXEMPTION ON THE FACT
THAT WE REMOVE A PUBLIC
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW PROCESS --
FOR THAT.
COOL I WILL SPEAK TO THAT.
MANUFACTURING OR DESPITE OUR OUR
SALES BUT I WILL SPEAK TO
CULTIVATION WHEN WE ARE LEARNING
THAT THERE ARE AT AND REALLY
MEANINGFUL TRADE OFF
SPECIFICALLY -- IN MY DISTRICT
AROUND AGRICULTURE -- THAT THOSE
PUBLIC ENVIRONMENTS REVIEW
PROCESS -- HELPS US BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'VE LEARNED IS
THAT -- WELL NOT ALL
AGRICULTURAL COUGH CROPS AND
MISSION THE SAME WAY AND SO
WE'VE HAD A NUMBER OF EXAMPLES
COME UP -- I WOULD SAY OVER THE
LAST TWENTY FOUR HOURS THERE'S
BEEN A NUMBER OF JOURNALISTIC
PIECES THAT DESCRIBES SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES -- THAT WE HAVE A
IN CULTIVATION AND THEY ALSO
KNOW THAT THERE HAVE BEEN ABUSES
IN THE LICENSING PROCESS.
AND SO I AM TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT PROTECTIONS ARE IN PLACE
FOR LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES TO
ENSURE THAT ONE WE MEET THAT
DESIRE AND THE WILL OF THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
BUT TO THAT WE ALSO PROTECT ALL
OTHER ECONOMIC ENGINES FOR OUR
COUNTY IN PARTICULAR WITH ADD
PESTICIDES DON'T MIX -- THE
SPACE BETWEEN CROPS ON THE
MATTERS TECHNOLOGY THAT WE HAVE
IN PLACE RELATED TO ORDER OKAY
HAS BEEN FOR OTHER CROPS AND NOT
NECESSARILY CANNABIS TO THINGS
ARE NOT NECESSARILY WORKING.
IN THE WAY THEY HAVE SO I'M
HOPING THAT YOU CAN SPEAK TO
THAT AND WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO
TO ENSURE THAT LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES HAVE THE
RESOURCES FOR ENFORCEMENT THE
RESOURCES ALSO TO DEAL -- WITH --
THESE ISSUES THAT ARE QUICKLY
ARISING PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT
THAT THE SEQUENCE EMPTION AND
THE PERFECT -- TEMPORARY PERMITS
GO THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY FIVE SO
FROM MY LOOK IF IN TWELVE MONTHS
WE'VE LEARNED THIS MUCH I JUST
WONDER AM IF EXTENDING IT
ANOTHER SIX YEARS -- WITHOUT A
PUBLIC -- PROCESSES -- TO TO
REVIEW THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS
WHAT ELSE ARE WE GONNA LEARN AND
WHAT KINDS OF HARDSHIPS ARE WE
PLACING ON MUNICIPALITIES WHO
HAVE.
FOLLOWED THE WILL OF THE PEOPLE
ON IN OUR EXCEEDING I THINK THE
EXPECTATION.
SO I THINK THAT THERE'S A FEW
IMPORTANT POINTS THAT REALLY
THAT INTENTION HERE BEHIND THAT
PROVISIONAL LICENSE AUTHORITY IS
TO BE USED AS A STEP UP LICENSE.
AND REALIZING THAT WERE IN A
MARKET THAT'S IN TRANSITION --
IT'S STRUCTURED IN A WAY WHERE
IS -- AS IT RELATES TO SEE WHEN
FOR EXAMPLE THAT IF IT'S NOT
COMPLETE THAT NEEDS TO BE UNDER
WAY.
IT ALLOWS THE LICENSING
AUTHORITIES TO REVOKE OR SUSPEND
SOMEONE'S LICENSE IF THEY'RE NOT
ACTIVELY AND DILIGENTLY PURSUING --
ANYA LICENSURE WHICH WOULD BE
COMPLETION OF SEA QUEST -- BUT
THIS IS PROVIDING FLEXIBILITY
THAT RELIES DEFINITELY ON THE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS IN SOME WAY
BECAUSE THEY ARE DEFINITELY THE
KEEPERS OF THE SEQUEL PROCESS --
BUT IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT THIS DOESN'T REMOVE ANY
LOCAL -- JURISDICTION DISCRETION
SELF LOCAL JURISDICTION CHOOSES
TO REQUIRE COMPLETION OF C. BUT
BEFORE -- GETTING A PROVISIONAL
LICENSE THAT THAT IS STILL
ALLOWABLE UNDER THIS TRAILER
BILL -- OR ANY OTHER LOCAL
ORDINANCE THAT THEY CHOOSE -- I
WOULD ALSO SAY THAT IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS -- ARE STILL KIND OF
WORKING THROUGH HOW TO
INCORPORATE -- COMMERCIAL
CANNABIS ACTIVITY INTO THEIR
EXISTING SEQUEL PROCESS AND THAT
THEY DO HAVE A LOT OF
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEWS THAT ARE
ALREADY TAKING PLACE ON SOME OF
THESE BUSINESS OPERATORS AS THEY
WOULD ANY OTHER BECAUSE THEY ARE
ALREADY DOING -- THE LEAD AGENCY
AND LOOKING AT DISCRETIONARY
VIEWS FOR VARIOUS PROJECTS SO I
BELIEVE THAT STILL ALLOWS FOR
THAT DISCUSSION SOME REVIEWS ARE
TAKING PLACE -- AND ADD THAT WE
AREN'T REMOVING ANY DISCRETION
FROM THE LOCALS TO SORT OF
REQUIRE FURTHER -- SEQUIN
DILIGENCE IF THAT'S WHAT THEY
PREFER.
AND I APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE NOT
REMOVING DISCRETION I GUESS I
JUST THE PART I DIDN'T HEAR IS
WHAT PROTECTIONS ARE WE PUTTING
IN PLACE FOR LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES TO DEAL WITH THE
TRADE OFFS.
OF WHAT IS -- NOW ISSUES BETWEEN
AGRICULTURE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
AIR QUALITY -- I MEAN PESTICIDES
BRAIN I HAVE A LIST ON IN
ADDITIONALLY WHAT PROTECTIONS
ARE YOU PUTTING IN PLACE HERE
FOR LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES TO DEAL
WITH THE ABUSE OF THE PROCESS.
AT THE LIGHTS TEMPORARY LIKE SO
WITH SO AGAIN THAT THE THE THE
POWER TO REMOVE SOMEONE FROM
LICENSURE STILL WITHIN THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS POWER SO THEY MAKE
A DETERMINATION THAT THOSE
FACTORS.
ARE CREATING -- SOME LOCAL
HAZARDS THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED BY REMOVING LICENSURE
FROM SOMEONE THEY CAN BY THE
STATE AND WE CAN -- SUSPEND OR
REVOKE THEIR LICENCE ENTIRELY SO
THAT'S DEFINITELY A PROTECTION
IT ALSO SPECIFIES AGAIN -- THAT
THEY NEED TO BE -- THE
INDIVIDUALS NEED TO BE WE
DILIGENTLY ACTIVELY PURSUING THE
COMPLETION OF THEIR ANNUAL
LICENSE SO THE HOPE THERE IS
OBVIOUSLY THAT IF PEOPLE ARE
JUST GETTING A PROVISIONAL AND
NOT DOING ANYTHING THEN THEY CAN --
BASICALLY HAVE THEIR LICENSE
REMOVE SO AND I THINK THE OTHER
THING TO NOTE IS THAT SOME OF
THE WHAT'S TAKING PLACE ON THE
LOCAL LEVEL WAS DONE THROUGH THE
TEMPORARY LICENSE PROCESS AND
THE PHASE THAT WE'RE MOVING INTO
IS NOT TEMPORARY LICENSES.
IT'S PROVISIONAL ANY ANY
LICENSES THEY HAVE TO PAY THEIR
ANNUAL LICENSE FEE REGARDLESS OF
WHAT CATEGORY THERE AND THAT THE
FOLLOW ALL ANNUAL LICENSE
REQUIREMENTS.
THEY HAVE TO BE IN TRACK AND
TRACE -- SO IT IS A DIFFERENT
TYPE OF LICENSE THAT REMOVING TO
IN THIS IN THIS SPACE AND SO I
THINK THAT THERE ARE I
SUFFICIENT PROTECTIONS THAT ARE
IN PLACE.
UNDER THIS NEW STRUCTURE THAT
WERE WERE SORT OF ACTUALLY IN
THE MIDST OF AND THAT WERE IN
PLACE EVEN TWELVE MONTHS AGO.
I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS I
WOULD ASK US.
TO DO YOU CAN DIG DEEPER A
LITTLE BIT DEEPER BECAUSE I
THINK THAT WHILE THE INTENT IS
THERE -- I AM NOT SURE THAT IT'S
GOING TO MANIFEST ITSELF IN A
WAY THAT ACTUALLY DOES
EVERYTHING THAT IS INTENDED. TO
DO FOR LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES I
THINK AGRICULTURE IS A VERY BIG
PART OF OUR STATE AND CERTAINLY
CANNABIS IS PART OF IT -- BUT WE
WANT ALL CROPS TO BE ABLE. TO
MOVE FORWARD IN A WAY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- THAT
DOESN'T DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT
AND WE'RE LEARNING A LOT ABOUT
IT AND I HOPE THAT AND AS
DISCUSSIONS CONTINUE ABOUT THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE -- THAT WOULD
TAKE A LITTLE BIT DEEPER THE
INTENT IS THERE AND I'M NOT
GOING TO ARGUE THAT BUT I DON'T
SURE THAT THAT'S THE WAY THAT
IT'S MANIFESTING ITSELF IN
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE FOLLOWING
THE WILL OF THE PEOPLE -- AND IN
DOING SO TO A GREAT EXTENT THANK
YOU IN JUST TWO LAST POINTS ON
THIS THAT ARE ACTUAL AND
ORIGINAL TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
DID NOT HAVE A SUNSET ON THE
LANGUAGE SO WE HAVE AGREED TO A
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE CENTS AT AND
WE HAVE AGREED THAT -- TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
ADMINISTRATIVE CLARITY ABOUT
WHAT SEQUEL UNDER WAY MEANS SO
WE CAN ACTUALLY MOVE PEOPLE
THROUGH THAT PROCESS AND ADDRESS
ANY -- ENVIRONMENTAL -- PROBLEMS
THAT THEY MAY BE CREATING AND I
APPRECIATE THE THE CHANGES I
ALSO THINK THAT I GO BACK TO TO
TO A COMMENT THEY MADE THE IN
TWELVE MONTHS -- BUT WE'VE
LEARNED A LOT IN THE STATE ABOUT
WHAT IS NOT WORKING AND SO AS WE
THINK ABOUT THE REASON -- AND
THE TIMELINE FOR HOW LONG WE'RE
GOING TO EXTEND THIS PROCESS
WE'RE GOING TO BE LEARNING MORE
SO IF WE LEARNED THIS MUCH IN
TWELVE MONTHS I SUSPECT THAT
WE'RE GONNA LEARN DUBLIN IN.
ANOTHER TWELVE MONTHS AND SO THE
LONGER WE PROJECT THAT AL ON THE
MORE REAL LEARN AND I THINK WE
NEED TO ALSO BE IN A POSITION TO
EMPOWER OUR LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES
TO DEAL WITH SOME OF THE TRADE
OFFS THAT ARE COMING.
WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
[inaudible]
THIS REVIEW.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WOULD
LIKE TO THINK THE ADMINISTRATION --
FOR BRINGING THIS PROPOSAL
FORWARD THE UNDERGROUND MARKET
AS WE ALL KNOW AS A HUGE PROBLEM
IN CALIFORNIA I THINK THIS BILL
WILL GO A LONG WAY IN ENFORCING
THE LAW -- MY CONCERNS -- ARE
THAT THE TAXES THAT WE WERE
PROMISED WE'RE GOOD AND GOING TO
BE GENERATED WITH CANNABIS ARE
NOT BEING PRODUCED AND I THINK
THAT THE UNDERGROUND MARKET IS A
HUGE PROBLEM -- SO I JUST WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE ADMINISTRATION
AND YOU KNOW I AGREE WITH MISTER
MOM THAT WE NEED TO LOOK FURTHER.
AS TO AS TO HOW WE'RE GOING TO
ENFORCE IT -- I THINK WE'RE
PIECE MILLING A LOT OF THE
ENFORCEMENT -- ISSUES I I KNOW
SOME CITIES DON'T HAVE -- THE
CAPABILITIES. TO ENFORCE A LOT
OF THESE ISSUES SO I THINK THAT
THE STATE NEEDS TO PLAY A BIGGER
PART IN THE ENFORCEMENT PARTS I
JUST.
AGAIN WHEN I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION FROM BRING IT
FORWARD BUT I AGREE WITH MR ONE
WE HAVE TO KEEP -- DIGGING AND
LOOKING AT FURTHER ENFORCEMENT
OPTIONS NOT JUST FOR THE STATE
BUT FOR THE LOCAL MUNICIPALITY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES ARE.
AND I ALSO AGREED THAT THE THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY IS REALLY
WHAT'S KILLING US AND I COMMEND
IN THIS BILL THAT WERE ACTUALLY.
PROVIDING SOME -- SOME PENALTIES
FINANCIAL PENALTIES INSTEAD OF A
GOING BACK TO THAT OLD METHOD OF
ARRESTING EVERYONE FOR FOR USING
CANNABIS WE'RE LOOKING AT IF
YOU'RE LICENSEES FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND THIRTY THOUSAND IF
YOU'RE ON LICENSE AND THAT THOSE
MONIES.
HOPEFULLY WILL GO INTO THE CAMPS
CONTROL FUNNY CAMPUS PRIZE IN
THESE FUN IN IN ONE DAY WE LOOK
UP AND THERE'S THERE'S ENOUGH
MONEY THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY GIVE
MONEY TO LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WHICH I'VE BEEN FIGHTING FOR FOR
THE LAST -- TO BUDGET CYCLES TO
GIVE LIKE A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS CASH TO GO INTO
COMMUNITIES WORK WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO SHUT DOWN -- THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY -- I FIRMLY
BELIEVE IF WE START MAKING THIS
FINANCIALLY A DIFFICULT FOR THE
LEGAL MARKET -- THOSE NUMBERS
WILL GO DOWN FOR EXAMPLE MIGHT
HIM IN MY AREA IN LOS ANGELES
THERE'S ONLY ABOUT A HUNDRED
THIRTY LEGAL TO SEVENTEEN
HUNDRED ILLEGAL -- DAY ABOUT IT
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS PER DAY
IF YOU FIND EVERY LAST ONE OF
THEM.
WE GET THAT NUMBER UP PRETTY
HIGH AND PEOPLE START LOOKING AT
THAT FINES AND FEES.
ACCOUNT.
AND SO HOPE WE CAN REPURPOSE
THAT.
INTO COMBAT IN IT AND HOPE WE
DON'T USE IT FOR OTHER THINGS
OTHER THAN COMBATING CANNABIS
AND SO -- I COMMEND YOU ON ON
DOING THAT -- IN ADDITION.
IT'S REALLY GOOD THAT WE HAVE
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
EQUITY PIECE.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN -- DAMAGE
BY THE CAMPUS MARKETING BEING
ARRESTED -- NOW CAN USE THIS IS
DOES INDUSTRY THEY CAN NOW BE
PART OF IT I'M TIME I HAVE
COMMITTED LATINOS WHO.
WERE INCARCERATED FOR QUITE SOME
TIME IN OUR OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE
BEEN TOTALLY DAMAGED BY WE CAN
TAKEN OUT.
GOING TO THIS MARKET AND WE HAVE
A VEHICLE FROM A STATE
PERSPECTIVE -- MANAGED BY THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WHICH IS
REALLY GOOD THAT WE HAVE
SOMEBODY THAT'S IN CHARGE TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
AND IN ON ITEM NUMBER TWELVE I
WOULD ONLY CAUTION YOU -- YOU
WANTED EXTEND SOME CONTRACTS TO
THE TO THE STATE DEPARTMENT
HEALTH SERVICES -- FOR YOUTH
PROGRAM FOR USE THAT OR DID
DESIGNED TO EDUCATE AND PREVENT
THEM.
BUT YOU WANT TO I GUESS
BASICALLY -- I HAVE THEM IN --
CONTRACTS WOULD NOT A LOT OF
OVERSIGHT OR LET US KNOW RETURN
ON INVESTMENT HOW THEY'RE
SPENDING THEIR MONEY WHERE THE
NOT THOSE PROGRAMS THAT THEY
GIVE THAT MONEY.
TO THAT THEIR EFFECTIVE.
LOOK I'M A FORMER BUREAUCRAT YOU
DON'T GIVE ME MONEY YOU DON'T
EXPECT ME TO COME BACK TO YOU
AND LET YOU KNOW HOW I SPENT IT.
WE ARE NOT SPENT WISELY AND MOST
IMPORTANT WHEN I WAS THE BEST
USE OF THOSE FUNDS SO I I WOULD
CAUTION YOU NOT TO JUST.
ALLOW.
THE DEPARTMENT YOU JUST USED TO
MONEY AT THEIR AT THEIR OWN
EXPENSE AND THEN FINALLY HAVE A
KIND OF A QUESTION ON THE CANVAS
ON NINE ONE FIVE TWO KENNETH TO
CONTROL APPEALS PANEL -- WHICH
WILL BE ESTABLISHED I DO NOT
UNDERSTANDING.
WHY YOU WANT TO GIVE THEM CLOSE
SESSIONS -- AUTHORIZED A PANEL
TO HOLD A CLOSED SESSION FOR THE
PURPOSE OF HOLDING A
DELIBERATIVE CONFERENCE.
LOOK WE HAVE GRAND JURIES TO
HAVE CLOSE SESSIONS AND WHEN IT
COMES -- TO USE OF FORCE IN
OTHER THINGS WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
GOES ON IN A SO I'M I'M HOPING
THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS MEANS THAT.
YOU HAVE PRIVATE MEETINGS.
WHERE NOBODY CAN COME IN AND SEE
WHAT THE CANNABIS CAN CONTROL
APPEALS PANEL IS DOING OFFICE
TRANSPARENT ENOUGH SO THAT WHEN
SOMEONE IS DENIED?
AN APPEAL OR IF THEY GET IT THE
PUBLIC WILL KNOW WHAT GOES ON IN
THOSE THOSE COMMITTEE ME SO I
GET SOME CLARIFICATION ON WHAT
THAT MEANS I'M HOPING IT'S NOT
LIKE A TO JURY.
WHERE WE SHOULD GO IN SECRET AND
MAKE DECISIONS?
YEAH MY UNDERSTANDING OF THE
CHANGE ITS TECHNICAL IN NATURE
THE ALCOHOL BEVERAGE CONTROL
APPEALS PANEL HAS THE SAME
AUTHORITY IT WOULD JUST ALLOW
THEM TO HAVE THOSE CLOSED.
DOOR DISCUSSIONS TO DELIBERATE
AND SEEMS TO THAT SOMETHING
COMMON OF BOARDS SO THE CLOSEST
SESSIONS -- FOR MAYBE DEALING
WITH THE LAWYERS COMING IN --
LEGAL MATTERS TO TO SHOULD TALK
OUTSIDE IN THE PUBLIC THAT DOES
THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING OKAY.
THANK [inaudible]
THIS RACE.
THANK YOU MISTER.
I WANT TO LEND MY VOICE TO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMB ON
REGARDING THE SEQUEL EXCEPTION.
IT IS A SERIOUS CONCERN -- AND
I'M NOT SURE THAT.
BUT I HAVE A HANDLE ON EXACTLY
WHAT THIS PROCESS IS GOING TO BE.
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF WAREHOUSES
IN OUR DISTRICT AND THE SEEK.
PROCESS IS PROBABLY ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT AND EVEN WITH
THAT.
WE ARE STILL THE WAREHOUSE
CAPITAL.
OF THE WORLD.
I DON'T WANT THIS TO BE.
A USED AS A LOOPHOLE. TO ALLOW.
THESE WAREHOUSES TO COME INTO A
COMMUNITY.
USUALLY COMMUNITIES WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ISSUES --
ALREADY PLAGUING THEM TO KNOW A
LOT ALLOW.
INDUSTRY RELATED TO CANNABIS TO
USE THAT EXEMPTION. TO FOREGO
THE SEQUEL A PROCESS THAT IS SO
IMPORTANT TO OUR COMMUNITIES.
I WANT TO BE SURE.
THIS IS NOT THIS IS INCORRECT.
SO I THINK I THINK AS I ARE TAKE
YOU LATER THAT THAT REALLY THE
SEQUEL PROCESS IS STILL -- OWNED
AND AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND SO
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE IS
PROVIDE FOR ALLOWANCES TO KEEP
PEOPLE IN LICENSURE.
SO IF A LOCAL JURISDICTION IS IN
THE MIDST OF DETERMINING HOW
THEY DEFINE -- COMMERCIAL
CANNABIS SYKORA-- AND THEY HAVE
THEIR OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEWS AND THEY KNOW THAT THEY
HAVE AN OPERATOR THAT'S YOU
DILIGENTLY WORKING TOWARDS --
LICENSURE AND COMPLETING SEQUEL
EVEN THOUGH IT MAY BE UNDEFINED
THERE -- THAT THEY DON'T WANT.
TO DENY THAT PERSON A LICENSE SO
THIS JUST AS AN ALLOWANCE FOR
THEM TO KEEP PEOPLE ON LICENSURE
BECAUSE I THINK THE ALTERNATE IS
THAT IF WE MAKE THE BARRIER TOO
HIGH AND WE AREN'T CONSIDERED OF
WHERE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE
ABOUT SORT OF THEIR SEQUEL
PROCESS WE COULD HAVE.
IT THAT WE JUST PUT UP TO BIGGER
BARRIERS AND PEOPLE WON'T BE
ABLE TO ACCESS THE LEGAL MARKET
AND THEY COULD CONTINUE INTO THE
ILLEGAL MARKET SO.
I MEAN THAT'S REALLY THAT THE
THE THE POLICY POINT HERE IS
THAT IF IT WERE NOT A FULLY
EXEMPTING PEOPLE FROM SEEK
WHETHER TO THE SEQUEL EXEMPTIONS
ARE.
IF YOU HAVE A LOCAL ORDINANCE IN
PLACE HOUSE YOU HAVE TO REQUIRED
DISCRETIONARY REVIEW LOCALLY FOR
SITE SPECIFIC.
PROJECTS SO YOU JUST YOU HAVE TO
COMPLETE YOUR SEEK WHAT PROCESS
ON THE ACTUAL AUTHORIZATION AT A
LATER DATE.
AND THE SECOND ONE IS SAYING
THAT IT HAPPENED SPEAK WHAT HAS
TO BE UNDER WAY FOR THE LICENSEE.
AND WE ALSO HAVE A PROVISION
THAT SAYS IF THE JURISDICTION
TELLS US THAT THEY'RE NOT
DILIGENTLY ACTIVELY WORKING
TOWARDS THAT THAT WE CAN SUSPEND
AND REVOKE THEIR LICENSE.
SO IT'S NOT WITHOUT WERE ASKING
TO LIKE FOR FULL SEQUEL -- NON
COMPLIANCE WE REALIZE THAT
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT ELEMENT BUT
WE REALIZE THAT THIS IS A MARKET
IN TRANSITION THAT NEEDS A
PERIOD WHERE WE CAN HAVE PEOPLE
THAT ARE IN OR PART WAY AND SO
WE CAN GUIDE THEM TO FULL
LICENSURE.
AND IT'S A PROTECTION OF THE
ENVIRONMENT IN THE LONG TERM I
THINK.
TO I WANT TO BE SURE.
THROUGH THE THROUGH THE CHAIR.
I DO WANT TO BE SURE THAT WE
DON'T.
WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
BALANCE?
IN.
IN THIS THIS SPACE.
THAT WE DON'T GIVE MORE VALUE TO
A BUSINESS ENTITY SIMPLY BECAUSE
IT'S A BIT CANNABIS BUSINESS
ENTITY.
ON THE BALANCE WITH A COMMUNITY
THAT IS GOING TO HAVE.
THIS ENTITY IN THEIR MIDST.
OUR OUR OUR COMMUNITIES ALREADY
ARE OVER BURDENED IN SO MANY
WAYS.
AND SEEK WELL THE SEQUEL PROCESS
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. FOR
PROTECTIONS FOR OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND IF.
A LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS.
IS ALLOWED TO DECIDE WHETHER A
CANNABIS BUSINESS IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN THE HEALTH OF
THEIR COMMUNITY.
AND THEY SIDE WITH CANNABIS THAT
IS EXTREMELY.
PREJUDICIAL TO COMMUNITIES LIKE
MINE.
SO I HOPE THAT.
THOSE DISCUSSIONS CONTINUE AND
I'M SURE THAT THEY WILL.
A ONE MORE QUESTION IF I MAY --
MISTER CHAIR.
IN THE LANGUAGE ITSELF WHERE
TALKS ABOUT THE LOCAL EQUITY
PROGRAM WHICH I THINK IS A
LAUDABLE -- IDEA.
IN ONE OF THOSE -- ONE ONE
ASSISTANCE.
THE ASSISTANCE IT THERE CAN BE
PROVIDED.
TO THOSE DEALING IN CANNABIS.
IT STATES ASSISTANCE SECURING
CAPITAL INVESTMENTS FOR DIRECT
ACCESS TO CAPITAL.
IS THIS SOMETHING MORE THERE'S
PROVIDE THAT WOULD BE PROVIDED
TO OUR LOCAL -- SMALL BUSINESSES
[inaudible]
SO -- THE I MEAN THE THIS
FUNDING IS SPECIFIC TO THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY -- THERE ARE
SMALL BUSINESS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE CENTERS -- AND WE
ACTUALLY ESTABLISHED A TWENTY
MILLION DOLLAR PROGRAM STARTING
LAST YEAR THROUGH THE OFFICE THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT WHERE
THEY'RE ACTUALLY SUPPLANTING
FEDERAL DOLLARS AND PRIVATE
DONATIONS SO THAT THEY CAN
PROVIDE MORE GENERAL BUSINESS
ASSISTANCE TO SMALL BUSINESSES
SO IT'S NOT.
REFLECTED HERE BUT THIS IS VERY
UNIQUE AND SPECIFIC BECAUSE
UNFORTUNATELY THIS INDUSTRY HAS
LIMITED I KEPT ABILITY -- TO
RECEIVE FINANCING THROUGH BANKS
AND THROUGH THOSE TYPICAL
PROCEDURE SO A LOT OF THIS YEAR
IS IN A WAY TO GIVE -- THOSE
LOCAL BUSINESSES AND START UP
CAPITAL POTENTIALLY SO THAT THEY
CAN GET INTO BUSINESS --
BUSINESS IN THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY BECAUSE THERE ARE
CERTAIN LIMITATIONS.
THAT MAKE IT UNIQUE.
AND YOU USING FEDERAL FUNDING AS
WELL.
TODAY NOT NOT FOR THIS NOT FOR
THIS CANNABIS THAT THAT'S FOR
THE SMALL BUSINESS -- PROGRAM A
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE IN EXISTENCE TODAY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
A SINGLE PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
ALBERTO TO RECALL THE UP TO THE
UNITED FOOD AND COMMERCIAL
WORKERS IN SUPPORT OF THE BUDGET
I TRAILER BROKE.
JUST A COUPLE OF COMMENTS YEARS
AGO WAS INVOLVED IN CANNABIS
BECAUSE WE SEE IT AS A I WAS
HERE GROWING BURGEONING INDUSTRY.
WE WANT TO SHOW THAT THE JOBS
THAT ARE CREATED OR MIDDLE CLASS
JOBS WITH GOOD.
GOOD WAGES A COUPLE OF THINGS I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT FOR THE
MEMBER'S COMMENTS THERE.
IN KEEPING WITH THE SPIRIT.
THE UNLICENSED UNDERGROUND
OCCULT UNDERGROUND COMPANIES ARE
HURTING.
THE LEGITIMATE LICENSE COMPANIES
SO IN PORTION OF THIS IS IT'S
CRITICAL SIDE ONE OF THE CO COME
TO MISTER JONES SAWYER AND HIS
RUBIO.
SECOND WERE ALSO VERY MUCH
COMMITTED TO SOCIAL EQUITY PIECE
OF OF CANNABIS IN THE IN THIS
GOING INDUSTRY.
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE BILL BECAUSE
OF THE THE PROVISIONS IN THE
BILL THAT ARE GOING.
TO ASSIST AND ENCOURAGE MORE
GROWTH IN THESE IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
REALLY IMPACTED BY THE
PROSECUTION OF CANNABIS -- LAST
FIFTY YEARS THANK YOU.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS ROBERT HARRIS
ON BEHALF OF US YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE NO INTEREST IN
ORGANIZING WORKERS IN THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY UNLIKE OUR
BROTHERS AND SISTERS THE UFCW.
OUR INTEREST IN THIS IS THE ONE
THE SOCIAL EQUITY PROGRAM.
WHICH IS CRITICAL TO THE
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT WERE RUINED
BY THE WAR ON DRUGS AND FAMILIES
WERE BROKEN APART.
THE SECOND THING IS.
WE DO A LOT OF THE ENFORCEMENT
INSPECTION IN SOME OF THE MAJOR
METROPOLITAN AREAS INCLUDING LOS
ANGELES.
AND WE WORRY ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY
WITH THESE [inaudible]
ILLICIT OPERATION SELLING
CONTAMINATED PRODUCT.
THAT HURTS PEOPLE.
AND WE THINK THAT THE BEST WAY
TO GO AFTER THAT IS.
THE POCKETBOOK AND SO WE APPLAUD
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR COMING UP
WITH THIS.
THE THE HIGH FINE SO YOU CAN
STOP THESE PEOPLE FROM ACTUALLY
OPERATING.
SO THAT'S IT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CARE MARTIN ST ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES REPRESENTING LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HERE IN SUPPORT.
I REALLY APPRECIATE -- THE
CONVERSATION WITH RESPECT TO THE
SEQUEL PROCESS BUT WE
ESSENTIALLY LOOK AT THIS BILL AS
A TIME EXTENSION FOR THE SEQUEL
PROCESS RATHER THAN A TRUE
EXEMPTION -- OPERATORS HAVE TO
DEMONSTRATE TO GET THAT
PROVISIONAL ANNUAL LICENSE FROM
THE STATE THAT THEY ARE WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THEIR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND THAT C. CA IS
UNDER WAY.
AND THAT REALLY IS A SORT OF THE
PURPOSE OF THIS -- THIS BILL IS
TO PROVIDE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ADDITIONAL TOOLS AND RESOURCES
TO GET THROUGH THAT PROCESS PROP
SIXTY FOUR ESSENTIALLY SET UP A
DUAL LICENSING SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA THE STATE HAS TO
ISSUE THERE -- LICENSE BUT THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THE ZONING AND LAND USE
PROCESS AND DEPENDING ON YOUR
JURISDICTION YOU REPROACH SEE
WHAT -- POTENTIALLY IN A COUPLE
DIFFERENT WAYS AND THAT TAKES
TIME CONDITIONAL USE PERMITS AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL CAN TAKE NINE
MONTHS TO TWELVE MONTHS SO
REALLY WE LOOK AT THIS AS A TOOL
TO KEEP OPERATORS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING.
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN
COMPLIANCE INTO THE REGULATED
MARKET PLACE INSTEAD OF
TRANSITIONING THEM INTO THE
ILLICIT MARKET PAID PLACE AND
THEN ALSO ON ON THE TAX PIECE
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT I THINK THAT
WE DO HAVE INCENTIVES AND TOOLS
FOR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE
INTERESTED.
IN REGULATING I'M SO THAT WE CAN
FULLY REALIZE THE TAX POTENTIAL
THAT CANNABIS -- BRINGS IN
CALIFORNIA WE DO HAVE A FEW
THINGS WE WOULD LIKE TO WORK OUT
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION ON THE
PAYING BACK BETWEEN THE STATE
AND THE LOCALS ON NOTIFICATION
OF WHOSE ISSUING LICENSES -- ONE
BUT WE LOOK AT THIS MEASURE AS A
CRITICAL STEP FORWARD AND
NECESSARY STEP FORWARD TO KEEP
OPERATORS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
INTO THE REGULATED MARKET PLACE.
THANK YOU.
MARIN BMB HALF OF THE UNITED CAN
AS BUSINESS ASSOCIATION THIS AND
AND I CAN THOSE BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION THE LONG BEACH
COLLECTIVE ASSOCIATION.
THE UNITED MEDICAL MARIJUANA
COALITION OUT OF SAN DIEGO THE
SAN FRANCISCO CANS RETAILERS
ALLIANCE.
THE COACHELLA VALLEY CAN WAS
ALLIANCE NETWORK.
AND WE WE CLEARLY HAVE SEEN --
DISPENSERS HAS HAVE SEEN A PRO
PROLIFERATION OF ILLEGAL SHOPS.
AND AND IT HURTS OUR POCKET BUT
BUT I THINK WHAT WE HAVE TO
REMEMBER TO THAT WE HAVE A LOT
OF IMMIGRANTS IN THE COMMUNITY.
A LOT I IMMIGRANTS THAT TIMES
ARE WALKING INTO SOME OF THE
SHOPS ARE YOU LEGAL.
AND DON'T KNOW WHETHER I SHOP IS
LEGAL OR ILLEGAL THEY MIGHT HAVE
PUT UP ANY LEGAL SHOP ON A AYE
ONLINE PLATFORM AND I'VE FOUGHT
FOR EMPLOYMENT.
THAT THE SHOP WITH SAM A PAY YOU
CASH BECAUSE THAT'S HOW
EVERYBODY PAYS IN THE INDUSTRY
SO BY HAVING A LARGE ILLEGAL
MARKING WHERE EXPOSING OUR
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY -- WE NEED
ENFORCEMENT PIECE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS PUT FOR
THERE'S NOTHING IN STATURE RIGHT
NOW THAT ALLOWS FOR AGENCIES TO
COME AFTER ILLEGAL OPERATORS WE
NEED THAT. ONE LAST PIECE ANY
LOCAL PERMIT ANY PERMIT HAS TO
FIRST BE APPROVED BY LOCAL
JURISDICTION BEFORE IT'S
APPROVED BY THE STATE.
SO I THINK AGAIN SEEK WAS ALWAYS
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAS CONTROL
FOR THAT THANK YOU.
JASON BRYANT ON BEHALF OF THE
HUMBOLDT COUNTY GROWERS ALLIANCE
AND THE CAMPUS DISTRIBUTION
ASSOCIATION -- WE SUPPORT THE
TRAILER BILL -- FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS BUT ALL DEFERRED THAT.
COMES BUT REDUCE LANE AND WE I
THINK HER SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
YOU.
HELLO ALLOW THE SAUDIS ON BEHALF
OF LOCAL BUT AT THE U. S..
CAMPESINO I CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT ECHO COMES AS BEFORE
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AMY JENKINS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF THE BUDGET TRAILER
BILL TODAY I WANT TO
PARTICULARLY NOTE THE COMMENTS
MADE BY C. SACK AND THE INDUSTRY
IS WORKING VERY DILIGENTLY -- TO
BECOME COMPLIANT WITH C. C<c.cyan></c>
AND THIS PROVIDES AN ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE LOCALS IN --
COOPERATION WITH THE LAWFUL
CANNABIS INDUSTRY TO COMPLETE
THAT PROCESS -- WE DID
ORIGINALLY SUPPORT THE IN
PERPETUITY OF THE PROVISIONAL
LICENSE WERE FINE WITH THE FIVE
YEAR -- WE THINK THAT REPRESENTS
A GOOD BALANCE -- ALSO WANT --
TO APPLY THE WORK THAT'S BEEN
DONE TO IMPROVE AND BOLSTER
ENFORCEMENT WE DO SUPPORT
PARTICULARLY THE FINES AND
PENALTIES IMPOSED ON UNLICENSED
RETAILERS -- MY PRIOR CALLING MR
PANETTA COMMENTED A LOT ABOUT
THAT AND THEY CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
EXPRESSED BY INDUSTRY THERE IS A
VERY VERY RAMPANT.
SIGNIFICANT ILLICIT MARKET IN
CALIFORNIA THAT IS HAS NO
INTEREST IN COMPLYING WITH ANY
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW PROCESS IS
NOT -- PRODUCING AND SELLING I
TESTED QUALITY ASSURED PRODUCT
SO THE ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL AND LASTLY
CCA STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT AND SOCIAL
EQUITY IT'S BEEN A CORPORATE E.
FOR THE ASSOCIATION.
AND WE THINK THE ADMINISTRATION --
FOR THAT CONTINUED SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MR TURN MEMBERS THE SUTHERLAND
SALAS WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY FIRST OFF WE WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THEM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOAN AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES FOR THEIR
COMMENTS ROUNDS HE WON THE
CONCERNS THERE.
WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A
TWO YEAR SUNSET FOR THE LOSS OF
THE PROVISIONAL LICENSE INS IN
LIEU OF THE PROPOSED FIVE YEARS
WE FEEL THAT FIVE YEARS IS TOO
LONG AT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD BE SITTING TOO MUCH
AUTHORITY.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE TWO YEARS IS
REALLY THE IDEAL TIME LINE IN
ORDER TO ENSURE BOTH PUBLIC
HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENTAL
INTEGRITY I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT
WE SUBMITTED A LETTER TO THE
COMMITTEE -- TO THAT EFFECT WITH
OUR PARTNERS CAL TROUT AND TROUT
UNLIMITED THANK YOU.
ANALYSTS RIVERO WITH DEFENDERS
OF WILDLIFE AND THE CALIFORNIA
LEAVE CONSERVATION VOTERS AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
MADE BY OUR COLLEAGUES AT THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT OF
A TWO YEAR EXEMPTION AND NOT.
FIVE I THINK VERY MUCH.
WHAT ARE WE DON'T KNOW WE HAVE A
OPPOSED TO LESS AMENDED -- FOR
THE PREVIOUS REASONS -- THAT OUR
OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL ADVOCATES
HAVE STATED WE DON'T THINK THAT --
THAT FIVE YEAR TIME PERIOD IS --
SHOULD SHOULD BE WITH THE WAY TO
GO WE BELIEVE A TWO YEAR PERIOD
IS A LOT MORE.
EQUITABLE AYE I'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS BRIEFLY -- WITH
SOME OF THE INDUSTRY AND WE'RE
WILLING TO HAVE A CONVERSATION --
TO COME TO A CONSENSUS ON THAT --
BUT WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE A TWO
YEAR -- EXEMPTION THANKS.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOING BACK IS FOR
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
OF THIS TRAILER BILL
[inaudible]
REGULATING ENCOURAGING
PARTICIPATION THE MARIJUANA
MARKET IS DIFFERENT.
THAN OTHER SMALL BUSINESSES WE
SUPPORT THE BEST AND OTHER SMALL
BUSINESSES.
BUT FOR MORE THA FIFTY YEARS
BLACK AND LATINO FAMILIES WERE
TARGETED FOR REST TEN KERR
SERRATION THE BREAD WINNERS OF
THOSE FAMILIES WERE TAKEN OUT OF
THE FAMILY PUT BEHIND BARS. FOR
FELONIES AND MISDEMEANORS.
THEY'RE NO LONGER ILLEGAL.
WE THINK A SMALL INVESTMENT IN
THOSE SAME COMMUNITIES THAT
SUFFERED THE WORST IMPACT OF
PROHIBITION IS APPROPRIATE.
SO THAT FAMILIES CAN TRYING TO
GAIN WEALTH AND TRANSFER WELL TO
THEIR CHILDREN THE NEXT
GENERATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO THE PUBLIC.
OKAY SEEING NONE LET'S MOVE ON
TO THE S. B.
.
ONE OH THREE SO SB ONE OH THREE
RATIFIES THE CONTRACT BETWEEN
THE ADMINISTRATION AND CCPOA --
THIS CONTRACT -- WOULD BE
FULFILLED UPON FUNDING
APPROPRIATED BY THE LEGISLATURE.
THAT BUDGET YOUR COST OF THE
CONTRACT FROM THE GENERAL FUND
IS ONE HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS
THAT'S IF YOU INCLUDE BOTH CCPOA
MEMBERS AND RELATED EXCLUDED
EMPLOYEES. FOR THE CONTRACT --
IT ALSO INCLUDES A 3% GS SIDE
GENERAL SALARY INCREASE IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THANK YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE
MISTER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO SEEMS
LIKE WE HAVE THIS DISCUSSION
EVERY TIME WE TALK ABOUT ANIMAL
YOU FOR THIS BARGAINING UNIT.
BUT KELLY CHAR IS SUPPOSED TO
GIVE US A COMPENSATION STUDY SIX
MONTHS BEFORE THE EXPIRATION OF
THESE MO USE.
WE STILL HAVE NOT HAD.
THEIR COMPENSATION STUDY FOR
THIS PARTICULAR BARGAINING UNIT
AND WE HAVEN'T HAD ONE SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN SO -- IT'S
DIFFICULT TO MAKE IT A FORM
DECISION ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
THIS IS A FAIR COMPENSATION
INCREASE WITHOUT THAT
COMPENSATION STUDY CAN YOU TALK
ABOUT WHY.
WE DON'T HAVE A STUDY.
MERRY ALTERMAN DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- IN THE PRIOR AMMO USE
THERE WAS AN AGREEMENT BETWEEN
ON THE MINISTRATION AND CZ PO
WAY. TO MEET CAN ON THAT TIME.
CONDITIONS OF HOW TO PUT
TOGETHER THE TOTAL COMPENSATION
STUDY AND NO AGREEMENT WAS
REACHED BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION SEES.
A ON HOW TO COMPLETE THE STUDY
ALRIGHT SO HOW ARE WE SUPPOSED
TO MAKE AN INFORMED DECISION IF
YOU GUYS CAN'T AGREE ON THE
METHODOLOGY FOR COMPLETING A
STUDY. TO GIVE US THE DATA THAT
WE NEED [inaudible]
SO I'M.
IN THIS AGREEMENT WE BELIEVE
THAT THE A GS SIZE THAT ARE
BEING -- PROPOSED A WILL THE 3%
FOR NEXT YEAR.
GIVEN THE CHANGES THAT WORK --
OBTAINING INTHE FISHING
OPERATIONS OF THE SYSTEM AND
WHAT THEY FOCUSED TOWARDS
REHABILITATION -- WE'VE FISKE
AGREEMENT IS REALLY FOCUSING
MOREON INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
GENDER RESTRICTED POSTS AND THE
ABILITY FOR WOMEN TO TRANSFER
INTO A FEMALE INSTITUTIONS AS
WELL AS ENSURING THAT
CORRECTIONAL COUNSELORS WILL BE
MORE ABLE TO FOCUS ON
REHABILITATION.
AND AND THAT THE INSTITUTIONS
WILL BE ABLE TO MAINTAIN
PROGRAMMING THROUGH THE
EFFECTIVE UTILIZED YOU DOES
UTILIZATION OF STAFF.
OKAY I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION FEELS THAT THIS
IS A REASONABLE.
INCREASE -- WE ARE TRYING TO
DECIDE IF WE AGREE THAT IT'S A
REASONABLE INCREASE THAT'S VERY
HARD TO DO THAT.
WHEN WE DON'T HAVE THE DATA IN A
COMPENSATION STUDY THAT'S DATA
THAT WE HAVE ON ALMOST EVERY
OTHER ANIMAL USE THAT WE
CONSIDER SO I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
YOU?
BEFORE YOU BRING AN ANIMAL YOU
BACK TO US FOR THIS PARTY UNIT
NEXT TIME PLEASE SIT DOWN AGREE
ON A METHODOLOGY GET US THE DATA
BECAUSE IT VERY MALE WALKING
VERY WELL MIGHT BE A REASONABLE
INCREASE.
IT'S DIFFICULT FOR US TO DECIDE --
WHEN WE DON'T HAVE THE DATA TO
MAKE THE DECISION?
I ALSO HAD A QUESTION ABOUT THE
BUDGET WE PASSED.
TODAY ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR
WHICH INCLUDED A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR BARGAINING.
BUT THAT WAS FOR ALL FIFTEEN OF
THE ANIMAL USE THAT EXPIRE THIS
YEAR AND YOU'VE JUST TESTIFIED
THAT THIS SINGLE AMMO YOU IS
GOING TO BE OVER I THINK WAS A
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN COST SO.
HOW DO YOU RECONCILE THOSE FACTS?
SO I BELIEVE.
SO WE DIDN'T QUIT THE BUDGET DID
INCLUDE AN INCREASE FOR
BARGAINING UNITS I NEED TO GET I
WILL GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT I
NEED TO DOUBLE CHECK THE
LISTINGS.
OKAY THANK YOU I I CAN ACTUALLY
RESPONSE I'M WE ACTUALLY
INCREASE THE AMOUNT IN THE
BUDGET YEAR FOR THE MO YOU I'M
IN LIGHT OF THE BARGAINING UNIT
SIX CONTRACT.
EXERCISE MORE THAN A HUNDRED
MILLION.
I'M SORRY I DIDN'T FOLLOW WHAT
YOU JUST SAID.
SO I AM IN THE BUDGET THAT'S
THAT'S BEING APPROVED TIME.
ONCE THIS IS ADOPTED THIS WILL
INCREASE THAT HUNDRED MILLION.
OKAY I UNDERSTAND SO DO YOU
THINK THAT THAT HUNDRED SO THIS
WILL INCREASE THE TOWN MUCH.
AND THIS WILL INCREASE IT BY --
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT
MILLION GENERAL FUND ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY ONE MILLION TOTAL.
OKAY SO THE TOTAL AMOUNT FOR
BARGAINING.
IN FISCAL YEAR TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TWENTY WILL BE TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY AND THIRTY
MILLION OKAY SO DO YOU THINK
THAT THAT HUNDRED MILLION.
IS GOING TO BE SUFFICIENT. TO
COVER ALL THE OTHER FOURTEEN AND
WILL USE THAT EXPIRE WE'RE STILL
IN NEGOTIATIONS WITH ALL OF THE
OTHER BARGAINING UNIT SO I'M
IT'S HARD TO TELL AT THIS MOMENT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE PUBLIC
[inaudible]
OKAY.
LAST TRAILER BILL SB.
ONE OH FIVE SERVICE FINAL
TRAILER BILL -- FOR THE CHANGES
TODAY DEALS WITH CORRECTIONS
FACILITIES PARTICULARLY THE
EXCEPT PROGRAM THIS IS THE
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM -- AND WHAT
THIS TRAILER BILL DOES IS IT
INCREASES THE MAXIMUM AUTHORIZED
COSTS FOR CBC ARE PROJECTS AND
IN PARTICULAR MAKES FORTY NINE
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
AVAILABLE FOR IT.
AND THIS WILL BE IN THE FORM OF
WEEKS REVENUE BOND FUNDING.
THANK YOU ANY UP QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEEING NONE OKAY.
WE ARE DONE.
THIS WILL CONCLUDE THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET THANK YOU